Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 38. Wieder ist etwas Zeit vergangen und es ist ja noch sehr viel mehr Zeit vergangen, wenn man etwas länger zurückblickt. Gibt es jetzt bald einen Geburtstag zu feiern und deswegen die heutige Sendung. Der Geburtstag ist der 25. Geburtstag des Chaos Computer Club. Eigentlich haben wir es ja nicht so mit dem Dezimalsystem und haben es schon zu anderen Zeiten gebührend feiern begangen, zum Beispiel auch zum 23. Aber trotzdem wollen wir jetzt das Ganze mal zum Anlass nehmen, einen kleinen Blick zurückzuwagen. Und dazu habe ich als Gast Peter Glaser mit dabei. Und dann wollen wir mal schauen, was sich damals alles so zugetragen hat. 001345, viele Zahlen. Hallo, willkommen beim Chaosradio Express. Eine weitere chaotische Ausgabe und ihr hört schon im Hintergrund den Peter, hallo Peter, am Grummeln und am Murmeln, am Warmlaufen. Peter, du bist der lebende Bleistift, stimmt's? Die Wikipedia will das zwar nicht wahrhaben, aber du bist einer, stimmt's?
Ja, jawohl.
Kannst du das mal erklären?
Ich bin als Bleistift geboren und habe mich inzwischen zu einem Schreibprogramm transformiert.
Aha, sehr gut. Und das lebt in Berlin, richtig?
Das Schreibprogramm lebt in Berlin.
Genau, genauer in Spandau, da befinden wir uns jetzt auch gerade. Und es ist immer wieder schön bei dir, es gibt immer schön was zu fixen.
Ich heb immer ein paar Probleme, auch für dich.
Das ist gut. Und heute habe ich auch ein kleines Problem mitgebracht. Das ist eigentlich nicht wirklich ein Problem, aber mir fehlt da so ein bisschen das passende Alter, um 25 Jahre zurückblicken zu können, zumindest was 25 Jahre CCC-Geschichte betrifft. Ich bin ja auch schon ein bisschen länger dabei, aber dich hat es ja relativ früh erwischt. Wann denn eigentlich?
Genau kann ich es dir nicht sagen. Es muss Anfang der 80er Jahre gewesen sein. Also die ersten Schatten sind auf mich gefallen. Das könnte gewesen sein, relativ kurz nach der Clubgründung, 82, 83. Es muss 82 gewesen sein, weil 83 bin ich nach Hamburg umgezogen. Und ich habe davor in Düsseldorf gelebt und in Düsseldorf bereits von einem Dr. Wau gehört, dessen Ruf ist ihm schon vorausgeeilt in Kreisen von Menschen, die Computer oder elektronisches Geät bedient haben. Und es war damals Kurt Talke, alias der Pyrrolator, prominentes Mitglied der Gruppe der Plan aus Düsseldorf, in Düsseldorf weltberühmt. Und der Kurt sagte zu mir, es gibt da in Hamburg jemanden, der Dr. Wau heißt und mit Computern zu tun hat. Und es gibt da einen Chaos Computer Club. Viel mehr wusste ich nicht, aber diese Begriffe, Dr. Wau und Chaos Computer Club, haben bereits eine stärkere fantastische Vorstellung in mir ausgelöst. Also von jemandem, der wie so ein Raketeningenieur mit so einem weißen Mantel rumläuft, mehrere Kugelschreiber und einen Rechenschieber in der Hemd- oder Manteltausche hat und so weiter und so fort. Das hat sich dann als eine sehr zur Wirklichkeit gegenteilige Vorstellung herausgestellt. Ich muss noch dazu sagen, das war damals eine Zeit, wo das sehr ungewöhnlich war, dass man mit, also dass ein Individuum, eine Privatperson mit Computern zu tun hat. Das fing in Deutschland alles gerade erst an. Ich hatte durch einen Zufall sehr früh einen Computer gekriegt. Und zwar gab es in Düsseldorf eine Sammelstelle für schriftstellerisch tätige Menschen verschiedener Couleur, das Literaturbüro Düsseldorf. Und in diesem Literaturbüro habe ich einen, sozusagen einen Bruder im Geiste kennengelernt, Matthias Schneider, der ursprünglich Linguistik studiert hat, von seinem Linguistikstudium. Alles, was ihm noch übrig geblieben war, war eine Katze, die Chomsky hieß. Und nach dem berühmten Linguisten, der ja heute mehr als Gesellschaftskritiker bekannt ist. Und der hatte irgendwann mal in den Ferien in dem Motorradgeschäft gearbeitet und lange Geschichte kurz erzählt. Jetzt verkaufte er hauptberuflich Motorräder, war da irgendwie hängen geblieben und hatte aus Amerika, von einer Amerikareise einen kleinen Computer mitgebracht. Sagt er also zu mir, er hat einen Computer zu Hause. Und das war, wenn damals zu einem jemand gesagt hat, ich habe einen Computer zu Hause, dann war das so, ich habe ein Anti-Schwerkraft-Gerät zu Hause, ich habe eine Mondraketen im Hinterhof und so.
Nachher kommt mein Freund, der Astronaut, vorbei.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, okay, will ich sehen, sind wir auf seinem Motorrad und zu ihm hin. Und da stand dann eine Art Plastik-Schreibmaschine, sehr hässlich, und ein kleiner Fernsehaberat. Es gab bestimmte Begrifflichkeiten gar nicht. Also es gab zum Beispiel den Begriff Computer-Monitor, gab es überhaupt nicht. Es gab nur kleine Fernsehaberate, die man da eben an diese Plastik schreibt. Und ich kann mich noch erinnern, als ich dann in dieses Zimmer rein bin, habe ich, muss sagen, ich bin dieser Technik sehr zugewandt gewesen. Ich bin ja mit dieser großen Technik-Euphorie in den 60er Jahren großgeworden, mit der ersten Mondlandung, mit dem Apollo-Programm und mit dieser Vorstellung von der Zukunft, die immer identisch war mit dem Jahr 2000. Das war so die große Ikone. Da gab es dann immer so diese Zeichnungen, Kuppelstädte, Schwebekleider und so weiter und so fort. Also wir wissen das ja heute, so wie die Zukunft ausschaut. Jedenfalls war, also Raketen und Computer, die man eben dazu brauchte, das war völlig klar, dass das irgendwie eine gute Sache ist. Und nur war keiner von uns sozusagen in die Nähe von so einem Gerät gekommen. Und da saßen die plötzlich im Wohnzimmer rum. Und das heißt, ich hatte nicht mitgekriegt, dass die schon so klein waren. Das heißt, ich habe die ganze Zeit unter dem Schreibtisch von Matthias geguckt, weil ich davon ausgegangen bin, das Ding muss doch mindestens so groß wie eine Waschmaschine sein und sagte immer, wo ist der Computer? Und das deutet eben auf diese hässliche Plastik-Schreibmaschine und ich sage, ist da alles drin.
War das ein Commodore 64?
Nein, das war ein Tandy, T-A-S-80, mit nicht entprellter Tastatur. Das heißt, wenn man irgendwie eine Zehntelsekunde zu lang am R gewesen ist, hat man 24 R am Bildschirm gehabt, schrieb nur Großbuchstaben und so weiter. Also das war alles noch richtig so, wie Gott den Computer geschaffen hat. Und dann habe ich einen Schlüsselmoment erlebt, dann hat Matthias ein Basic-Programm am Bildschirm vor mir ablaufen lassen. Und ich habe nur so eine, also in diesem Vorbeifließen gesehen, das ist eine Mischung aus Buchstaben, aus Worten, englischen Worten und Zahlen und ich habe das Gefühl, das ist eine Sprache und ich bin sofort von so einer Art Panik befallen worden, dass ich diese Sprache so bald wie möglich lernen muss, weil mir sonst der Zutritt zu Kuppelstädten und Schwebekleidern hinkünftig untersagt wird. Und ich bin da sehr früh einem Gefühl begegnet, von dem dann die nächsten zwei Jahrzehnte die ganze Weltwirtschaft irgendwie prosperiert hat, von dieser Panik, ne?
Der Cyberspace, alle mussten rein.
Genau, genau, genau. Die Blinden, die Lahmen und die Tauben wurden mit Tragbaden in den Cyberspace getragen. Das war aber dann in den 90er Jahren, als das Internet so explodiert ist. Und dann sagte Matthias so, jetzt darf ich auch mal. Und dann saß ich da, und ich hatte ja schon eine elektrische Schreibmaschine und so weiter. Das war damals quasi so das Allersbasicste, was man sich als Individuum vorerst mal zulegen konnte. Und ich tippte auf dieser Plastik-Schreibmaschine, tippte Hallo und dann war das sofort im Fernsehen. Und das ist jetzt was, man muss die Bedeutung dessen für die damalige Zeit nochmal dazu erklären, weil das heute irgendwie ein bisschen schwer vorstellbar ist, dass das ein besonderer Moment war. Ich bin mit dem Fernsehen sozialisiert worden, das heißt, ich bin aufgewachsen mit diesem Gerät, mit dem Fernsehaberat, als etwas, das wie so eine Schneekugel völlig geschlossen war, quasi diese Kathodenröhre, da konnte man nicht rein, da gab es die großen Sendeanstalten, die haben da das Programm hineingespielt und alles, was man als Fernsehzuschauer machen konnte, war laut, leise, hell, dunkel, ein, aus. Das heißt, das hatte ich 20 Jahre lang gemacht und plötzlich war da eine kleine Maschine und ich tippte Hallo und Hallo war im Fernsehen, in diesem, vor dem unzugänglichen Bereich und in dem Augenblick habe ich noch, ohne das wirklich zu wissen und zu verstehen, den Geist des Hackens begriffen, das heißt, dass der Computer eine Maschine ist, die einem den Zugang zu Bereichen ermöglicht, die man vorher nicht betreten konnte. Also so eine Art von Demokratisierung, auch Zwangsdemokratisierung, also das hat ja nicht jedem gefallen, dass dann diese Begriffe, es gab zwar vorher Videokameras und so, aber das war alles teuer und aufwendig, mit denen man sozusagen ein Bild in diesen Fernseher reinbringen konnte. Na ja, das war der erste Schritt.
Das heißt, du bist jetzt zunächst einmal von Düsseldorf nach Hamburg gezogen?
Ich bin erst einmal von Graz, ich bin ja Österreicher, wie man unschwer hören kann, immer noch. Da lege ich Wert drauf. Ich bin aus Graz nach Düsseldorf und bin dann von Düsseldorf 83 nach Hamburg umgezogen.
Und hatte das jetzt schon was mit dem CCC zu tun, dass du nach Hamburg gezogen bist?
Nö, das hatte mit dem Schreiben zu tun. Ich bin ja Schriftsteller und bin damals, also sozusagen, damals bin ich es geworden. Also in Graz wollte ich Schriftsteller sein und in Düsseldorf ist mir der Sprung ins Schriftsteller sein gelungen. Hab mein erstes Buch veröffentlicht. Das ist in Hamburg bei RoWold rausgekommen. Hier ist der große Hirnriss, neue Mitteilungen aus der Wirklichkeit. Und als ich das erste Mal in Hamburg war, habe ich in so einer Intuition gespürt, meines Bleibens wird in Düsseldorf nicht sein, weil ich komme aus so einem Kaff. Graz ist eine sehr kleine Stadt. Und ich bin ein paar Mal zu oft im Kino gewesen und habe die Lichter der Großstadt gesehen und hatte immer eine Vorstellung davon, dass ich war erst, war ich in Düsseldorf sehr schwer beeindruckt von der nächtlich beleuchteten Rheinkniebrücke, das war schon fast wie die Golden Gate Brücke, also jedenfalls, wenn man aus Graz kommt. Und als ich dann in Hamburg war, habe ich den Unterschied zwischen einer Großstadt und einer Weltstadt begriffen. Und das zweite war, dass ich gesehen habe, es war für mich als Autor eine Herausforderung, als junger Schriftsteller. In Düsseldorf war die Literaturszene, ohne ungerecht sein zu wollen, sehr übersichtlich. Und in Hamburg war es so, dass praktisch niemand in Hamburg nicht schon ein Buch geschrieben hat. Also das heißt, man hat auf so einem ganz anderen Level wieder eine Herausforderung gespürt. Und diese Herausforderung, die ist natürlich, wenn man 20 ist und noch was vor hat, ein großer Reiz. Die Stadt ist wunderschön. Ich hatte gute Freunde und ich habe eine Freundin, die hatte eine große Wohnung und da ist ein Zimmer frei geworden. Das war eine WG und das war parallel zur Reberbahn in der Seilerstraße. Also das heißt, mittendrin in dem, was Kleinhänzchen aus Graz sich unter einer großen Stadt vorstellt. Also Reisetasche gepackt auf noch haben.
Reberbahn ist schon ganz schön beeindruckend, wenn man das nicht gewohnt ist und da so als erstes mal hinkommt.
Ist völlig in Ordnung.
Also ich hatte da auch so ein bisschen Respekt am Anfang.
Ist völlig in Ordnung. Also so nach anderthalb, zwei Jahren hatte ich dann irgendwie genug davon, weil am Anfang war das natürlich toll, immer Party, 24 Stunden um die Uhr. Und damals war das mit dem Ladenschluss und so weiter und so weiter. Es ist ja alles extrem restriktiv noch gehandhabt worden in den frühen 80er Jahren. Und da gab es auf der Reberbahn die erste Aral-Tankstelle, die rund um die Uhr aufhatte. Das war wie in Amerika. Das war unfassbar. Also das war sozusagen großstädtischer Kontingent.
Von der ersten Robengleiterung.
Ja genau, damals habe ich noch Zigaretten geraucht. Das war alles sehr praktisch, weil die ganzen Piepshows und so weiter, die hatten immer Marksstücke, wenn man für einen Zigarettenattwarten gebraucht hat. Näher als einheimischer sieht man diese Dinge natürlich ein bisschen pragmatischer. Oder wir hatten dann so T-Shirts, auf denen drauf stand, I'm no tourist, I'm living here. Jedenfalls hatte er ein billiges WG-Zimmer, was bedeutet hat, es war einfach verglast, was wiederum bedeutet hat. Also man muss wissen, der Mensch hat ein bestimmtes Schamgefühl, auch wenn er schwer betrunken ist. Was bedeutet hat, dass, wenn der schwer betrunkenen Mensch auf der Reberbahn nicht mehr sein wollte, aus verschiedenen Gründen ist er in die Seitenstraßen gegangen. Und es waren immer wir, die Seilerstraße war die Parallelstraße. Und das heißt, da war dann irgendwie immer ein fröhliches Reiern und ein fröhliches Krakelen und so weiter. Und es war eben so 24 Stunden um die Uhr, das, was ich am Anfang so als Großstadt immer, sozusagen einpulsieren 24 Stunden um die Uhr empfunden hat. Das wird natürlich nach einer Zeit etwas zum Mürbend. Ich bin dann nach ein paar Monaten bevorzugt mit Schlafbrille und Ohrenstöpsel irgendwie schlafen gegangen, weil es gab halt keine ruhige Stunde. Und dann bin ich da, nach zwei Jahren, bin ich in einer bisschen ruhigeren Gegend weggezogen und bin dort dem Chaos Computer Club begegnet, in der Ohnerstraße.
In Form von Dr. Vau?
In Form von Dr. Vau. Und zwar, ich habe drei Freunde, Micha Sonntheimer, Benny Herrlin und Johnny Eisenberg. Und Benny kannte Vau. Und Benny kannte mich und Benny kennt die Menschen. Und wusste, die beiden wären ganz gut zusammen passen. Der wusste schon, ich bin so ein wunderbares Exemplar mit so einem Computer. Und er kannte den Vau und dachte, er bringt uns irgendwie zusammen. Und dann gab es einen. Ich habe mit so einem Model...
Das heißt, du hattest schon einen Computer?
Ich hatte einen Computer, ja. Und zwar einen. Erst in Düsseldorf hatte ich einen, weil mein Freund diesen TAS-80-Tandy hatte. Ich habe schon damals begriffen, was Kompatibilität bedeutet. Nämlich, dass man dann die Programme, dass ich die Programme, die mein Freund hatte, auch verwenden kann. Und ich habe mir eine Tandy-Kopie besorgt, einen Computer mit dem schönen Namen Genie 1. Daher segnet die Asiaten und ihren Kopiertrieb irgendwie. Das war so ein Ding, das sah aus wie so ein hässliches Plastikmisch-Bult mit einem eingebauten Kassettenrekorder. Diesen Kettenlaufwerke gab es damals noch nicht. Die Programme wurden auf Audiokassetten in normalen Bandlaufwerken abgespielt. Das hat dann manchmal bis zu fünf Minuten gedauert. Also bei Spielen oder so etwas aufwendigeren Sachen. Da blinkten nur zwei Sternchen an einem Bildschirm zu sehen. Eines stand still und das andere blinkte. Das heißt, er atmet, er lädt noch. Also wenn dieses zweite Sternchen aufhörte zu blinken, wusste man, Ärger. Irgendwie, man muss jetzt wieder von vorne anfangen. Aber vom Standpunkt des Betriebssystems her gesehen war das alles sehr übersichtlich.
Also das war jetzt ungefähr 83, als du dann nach Hamburg gezogen bist?
Das mit dem Sternchen war vorher, also der Genie 1 war 79,80. Nach Hamburg gezogen bin ich 82,83 in dem Übergang. Und dann bin ich da aus St. Baulig weg und da hatte ich einen C64 schon. Da ist der C64 rausgekommen und das war unfassbar, das war unfassbar. Das war und der ist damals hat er einen, also als ich mir den überhaupt leisten konnte, einen Verbilligungsschub erlitten, der wurde plötzlich um die Hälfte billiger, als was er vorher gekostet hat. Was bedeutete, dass der Computer nur noch ungefähr 700 Mark gekostet hatte und die Diskettenstation auch nur ungefähr 700 Mark. Die war genauso groß wie der Rechner und die war genauso teuer wie der Rechner.
War ja auch ein eigener Rechner.
Das ist ganz richtig, was du sagst, weil das gehört immer noch zu meinen bevorzugten Erinnerungen an die Zeiten im C64. Ich bin der Meinung, dass das, was man Unsinn nennt, in manchen Fällen Hochblüten, menschlicher Kreativität und Genialität und Virtuosität auch sind. Und es gab Programmierer, die haben die Diskettencontroller von dieser Diskettenstation vom C64 programmiert. Es gab ein Programmchen, mit dem man die rote Leuchtdiode an der Diskettenstation dimmen konnte. Das war ein Programm. Und eins, das ich besonders gern mochte, war, da konnte man mit dem Summen des Trafos, der in dem Gerät war, und dem Tackern von diesem Schrittmotor, dieser Steppermotor, der den Laufwerkkopf geführt hat, den Radetgemar, da konnte man den Radetgemar spielen. Also das war ein wirklich virtuoses Stück. Genau, das war nur die Diskettenstation. Und dann kam, ich hatte ja vorher erzählt, da war diese Vorstellung von Dr. Wau, von diesem grauhaarigen Raketeningenieur, und dann sagt Benni, ich muss dich jetzt mit Dr. Wau bekannt machen. Und dann ging die Tür auf, und dann kam so ein Waltschrad in der Krachleder rein, mit so einer Dreiviertellederhose, und ich dachte mir, was ist das denn jetzt? Und so ein Rübezahlbad, so ein Wanneproppen, so ein rundlicher Typ, der so einen Quitsch vergnügt und so. Und unfassbar, also das war die Realität.
Nannte sich Vau eigentlich selbst Dr. Vau? Nur Vau.
Nur Vau, und es wurde aber von ihm gesprochen als Dr. Vau. Also das war sozusagen eine gewisse Respektsbezeugung. Also wenn man von ihm gesprochen hat, hieß es Dr. Vau. Und wenn man, also gute Freunde nannten in Vau, und er hat sich selber mit Vau vorgestellt.
Ja, Vau, oder Vau Holland, oder Herward Holland-Moritz, um mal komplett zu sein. Ist ja leider 2001 verstorben und war einer der Gründer, aber im Wesentlichen eigentlich über Jahre das Clubgefühl am personifizierenden Persönlichkeit des Clubs. Gegründet wurde der Club ja nicht in Hamburg, sondern in Berlin, zumindest besagt das die offizielle Legende. Da gab es dieses Treffen in den Taz-Räumen. Hast du da mal nachgeforscht, was da eigentlich, oder nachgefragt, was da eigentlich konkret gelaufen ist?
Also es gab am 01.09.81 eine Kleinanzeige in der Taz, die sich beschäftigte mit der Zukunft des Computers im weitesten Sinne und den gesellschaftlichen Implikationen. Das war für die damalige Zeit schon sehr weitsichtig. Und vor allem, und das war wirklich nahe damit, dass Leute erahnten, dass da die PC-Revolution ist, das war auch schon von Personal Computer die Rede, dass die PC-Revolution vor der Tür steht und dass man dieses Gerät in die Hand nehmen kann und damit Sachen machen kann, die eigentlich sozusagen die große Geschäftswelt und die Leute, die bisher mit Computern gearbeitet haben und die da die Definitionshoheit hatten, noch überhaupt nicht auf dem Zettel haben. Und da wurde zu so einem Treffen eingeladen, das hat dann am 12. der als das eigentliche Gründungsdatum des Chaos Computer Clubs angesehen wird, 12. September.
Die Initiation ist 1. September sozusagen?
Genau, mit dieser Kleine Anzeige.
Das heißt, wir sind jetzt sozusagen on time, weil wir jetzt gerade den 1. September haben, wo wir dieses Gespräch aufzeichnen. Und dort haben sich, ich weiß nicht, hast du eine Ahnung, 20 Leute getroffen? Da haben sich 20 Leute getroffen.
Und da wurden dann auch kurz danach schon sowas wie Ideen, Sammlungen, Positionspapiere, auch politische Konzepte, Utopien usw. ausgetauscht, mehrseitige Papiere, die zum Teil auch noch im Chaosarchiv irgendwo rumfliegen. Das war schon ganz beeindruckend. Also sozusagen mit welcher, wie differenziert und mit wie klaren Absichten diese ganze Veranstaltung begonnen hat. Man muss jetzt dazu sagen, der Chaos Computer Club ist natürlich nicht vom Himmel gefallen. Das heißt, es gibt so Traditionen. Man muss den schon auch in so eine Tradition reinstellen, wenn man jetzt, ich kenne nicht alle von den Leuten, die damals an dieser Versammlung, die ja wie immer wieder auch geschrieben wird, an einem, also sozusagen an einem mythischen Objekt stattgefunden hat, nämlich in den Räumen der Tatsredaktion in den damaligen Räumen, stand der berühmte Tisch aus der Kommune K1. Den haben die dort wohl, weiß ich keine, Möbel in ihn transportiert. Das ist so ein relativ langer Tisch. Ich habe irgendwo im Internet mal einen relativ langen, aber relativ banaler Tisch, aber weil er eben aus der K1 war, war er irgendwie ein heiliges Objekt, kabalistisches Objekt. Wird immer gern zitiert, hat natürlich überhaupt keine Bedeutung, aber ich zitiere es auch. Damit hätten wir das erwähnt. Mythos, das macht ja Madonna auch, die bedient sich einfach irgendwie im Vorbeigehen an jedem Mythos, der irgendwo an der Hecke hängt und so. Was ich sagen wollte, ist, dass die Leute, die damals zu diesem Treffen gekommen sind, aus unterschiedlichen Traditionen kamen. Im Fall von zwei der Leute, gewisser Tom Twiddlebit, wie er sich in der Kleine Anzeige nannte, mit Nicht-Kampfnamen Klaus Schleisig und Vau Holland. Da gibt es eine nette Anekdote. Es wollte mal jemand Vau am Flughafen abholen. Die haben sich verpasst. Der kannte ihn nur unter Dr. Vau. Er hat ihn dann ausrufen lassen. Er wusste, ich möchte Herrn Vau Holland ausrufen lassen. Dann kam aus dem Lautsprecher, Herr Vau aus Holland, bitte zur Information. Er hat Vau gerne erzählt. Wenn man ihn gefragt hat, warum er eigentlich Vau heißt, ich glaube, so genau wusste er das selber nicht mehr. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass ich ihn ein oder zweimal gefragt habe, aber ich kann mich an eine klare Antwort nicht erinnern.
Das war, glaube ich, eine frühe Sache, Schule.
Kann gut sein, kann gut sein. Vau hat mir ein bisschen erzählt von den Dingen, die ihn in den 70er Jahren beeinflusst haben, die sein Denken und seine Interessen, die dann letztendlich in das geführt haben, was er im Chaos Computer Club entfaltet hat, geprägt haben. Dazu gehörten die Amateurfunker, die es schon lange, die es seit den 50er Jahren gab, und die immer so eine Jungskiste waren, irgendwelche Leute, die im Dachkämmerchen vor so einem beeindruckenden Amateurfunkgerät mit Röhren saßen und sich irgendwelche Stationskennungen aus Australien und Botswana-Land irgendwie zuschicken haben lassen und damit ihr Dachkämmerchen gepflastert haben. Das war irgendwie so eine Jungsgeschichte, oder man konnte ja zum Beispiel 1957 den Sputnik hören, der machte dann immer Piep, Piep, Piep und dann saß man in seinem Dachkämmerchen und hörte das echte Piep, Piep, Piep, irgendwie da von Sputnik 1. Also das war sozusagen, das ist natürlich ziemlich heutzutage ziemlich banal, aber dieses Gefühl von Authentizität und dass man einfach als Individuum da sitzt und mit diesem Gerät daran teilnehmen kann, das ist schon irgendwie nicht schlecht.
Auch diese Verkürzung der Distanzen, ich kenne das Gefühl, das erste Mal, als ich zur Kenntnis genommen habe, dass ein Text, den ich auf dem Computer gelesen habe, auf der anderen Seite das Planeten geschrieben wurde, das war auch so vollkommen erhebendes Gefühl, so Gott, diese Nachricht ist einen Tag alt, aber sie kommt aus San Francisco, kommt die auf meinen Computer. Wobei so schnell ging es gar nicht, es dauerte damals schon noch 2, 3 Tage, bis es um Planeten war.
Ich glaube, was Vau noch auf Gedanken gebraucht hat, war zum Beispiel die Tatsache, dass man hätte sich ja jetzt denken können, ok, ich habe ein Amateurfunkgerät, ich kann das jetzt benutzen statt meinem Telefon. Und das darf man aber nicht. Das heißt, es gibt eine Vorschrift, wenn du Amateurfunker bist, du darfst nur Gespräche führen, die sozusagen nicht so bedeutend sind, dass man sie am Telefon führen müsste. Das ist eine Regel gewesen jedenfalls. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie das formuliert worden ist, aber du hast sozusagen... Genau, förmlich. Und das ist natürlich eine Art von Kommunikationsrestriktion. Du darfst dein Amateurfunkgerät nicht einfach als Telefon benutzen. Und Vau war, soweit ich weiß, auch beim Militär der Fernmelder. Das heißt, er hatte schon ein gewisses Interesse, diesen Bereich der Kommunikationstechnik zu durchdringen.
Diese Regel gibt es ja jetzt auch noch. Wenn man sich heute einen Internetzugang kauft, dann wird das ja auch verboten, darüber ein Telefongespräch zu führen.
Echt?
Ja, wenn du dir eine UMTS-Flatrate kaufst, dann wird Voice-over-IP, also die angesagte Technik, die man jetzt auch mal ausprobieren will, die wird ja halt blockiert. Von daher hast du eigentlich dieselbe Restriktion immer noch. Sie dürfen da funken, sie dürfen banale Dinge übertragen, aber wenn sie sich ordentlich unterhalten wollen, dann haben sie gefälligstes Telefon.
Läuft nicht, genau, genau, läuft nicht. Von daher kann man sagen, da haben so Leute wie ich schon so einen kleinen eingebauten VOW jetzt in der Zwischenzeit, dass man dann einfach so diese Dinge also in so eine Tradition stellt und kritisch sozusagen beobachtet und kommentierend begleitet. Und was VOW gefallen hat und was VOW beeindruckt hat, waren so Dinge wie, dass die Amateurfunker einen eigenen Satelliten in die Erdumlaufbahn geschossen haben. Das ist schon nicht schlecht. Und was ihn vor allem beeindruckt hat, war sozusagen diese Nachbarschaftshilfe, diese technische Hilfe, die die Amateurfunker einander gegeben haben. Das heißt, wenn da einer war, der sagte, ich brauche hier einen Bauteil, ich habe irgendwie keinen Schaltplan, ich bin jetzt irgendwie hier oder da oder dort mit meinem Lateinern am Ende, da gab es dann immer Gruppen und Kommunikationen. Also das konnte man schon kommunizieren. Also über Amateurfunk konntest du dich natürlich über Amateurfunk unterhalten. Und das ist zum Beispiel was, was dann später mit UUCP, mit Newsnet und so weiter und so fort als eine Tradition aufgenommen und fortgeführt worden ist, weil IT&T zwar Unix freigegeben hat, aber keine Dokumentationen, dieses Betriebssystem Unix, und sich ein paar Leute veranlasst gesehen haben, um also sozusagen so eine Art von Nachbarschaftshilfe stattfinden zu lassen von Leuten, die sich für dieses Betriebssystem eben, dieses sehr komplexe, mächtige, aber ein bisschen nicht ganz so trivial zu verstehende, haben die eben ein eigenes Kommunikationssystem eingerichtet. Das ist eine Grundlage der Kommunikationskultur im Internet geworden ist. Das ist jetzt heute ein bisschen ein versunkener Schatz. Das Usenet gibt es zwar immer noch, aber das ist ein bisschen so eine, wie soll ich sagen...
Eine Wares-Abteilung geworden.
Ja, das steht etwas im Schatten der Geschichte, wie auch immer. Das war was...
Du bist aber Renaissance-fähig, wenn du mich fragst.
Ja, da kann man sich lang drüber unterhalten. Ich glaube auch, dass es, wenn man jetzt moderne Mittel der Informationsgewinnung, also wie man sozusagen die Perlen aus dem Schlamm baggern kann, das Problem im Newsnet ist ja immer die Menge an, die unfassbare Menge an Informationen, die da vorbei rauscht. Weil ich glaube, es gab zuletzt 70 oder 80.000 Newsgroups, also wo man versuchen musste, konnte sich irgendwie eine Art von Überblick verschaffen, wie auch immer. Das ist ein Seitenfraktal. Aber es gab noch eine zweite Tradition, was Vau mir erzählt hat, nämlich die Video, sogenannten Videoläden in den 70er Jahren. Das war ein bisschen ein Versuch der Linken, so ein bisschen in die moderne Technik einzusteigen. Also die Idee war, der Arbeiter wird mit einer Videokamera ausgestattet und dokumentiert, das Leben des Arbeiters und alles wird besser. Um das jetzt mal so ein bisschen verkürzt zu erklären. Also der Arbeiter schafft selber Kultur, dokumentiert seine Lebens- und Produktionsverhältnisse, klärt auf und so weiter und so fort. Da gab es so eine Tradition, da gab es dann eben so Videoläden, wo man sich Video-Equipment, das war ja damals alles etwas, also man musste dann immer schon so einen halben Bollerwagen mit den Akkus hinter sich herschleppen. Und jedenfalls, das war so ein bisschen angerissen, das waren so Dinge, die Bau aus den 70er Jahren noch mitgenommen hat. Also diese Fernmeldetechnischen Kenntnisse, die er nicht nur durch seine Militärzeit gewonnen hat, das ist ja in der Weise ein Amateurfunk. Und es gab im Chaos Computer Club dann später immer so eine Subgruppe, wo man wusste oder wo man gemerkt hat, ach, das sind Amateurfunker. Marku, Matthias Kühn und so weiter. Also das waren immer so eine, die haben so ein eigenes Selbstverständnis.
Es gibt ja auch jetzt noch eine...
Packet Radio und so Sachen in der Partie, ja.
Es gibt ja auch immer noch eine sehr starke Amateurfunker-Gruppe, auch im CCC, die Chaoswelle. Da sind sehr viele Leute auch involviert und das ist auch sehr technisch und sehr kommunikationsfreundlich. Ja, jetzt bist du also nach Hamburg gekommen und bist auf WoW und Konsorten gestoßen.
Ja, genau, erstmal WoW. WoW habe ich als ersten kennengelernt und allein. Den hatte Benny mal unterm Arm. Und dann ist der ganze Chaos Computer Club gekommen. Und das war wirklich eindrucksvoll. Ich habe in einem Haus gewohnt. Das war eine etwas feinere Gegend mit so einem kleinen Park hinterm Haus und einem Schwanenteich. Und so eine von diesen hübschen Hamburger Altbauten war es gestrichen mit ein bisschen Zirad um die Fenster herum. Parkett und hohen Decken mit Stock. Und dann war das Haus gerade eingeröstet, weil die Fassade irgendwie ein Alt war. Dann kam der Chaos Computer Club. Und ich weiß noch, an dem Abend kamen die Menschen zur Tür und zu den Fenstern. Überall kamen Leute rein. Das heißt, ein Teil vom Chaos Computer Club ist durchs Streppenhaus zu mir hochgekommen und ein Teil ist übers Gerüst hochgeklettert und beim Fenster reingekommen. Das heißt, die kamen durch alles, wo irgendwo eine Öffnung war in meiner Wohnung rein. So habe ich den Chaos Computer Club kennengelernt.
Das klingt aber jetzt nach einer Hundertschaft.
Wie viele Leute sind denn da aufgekreuzt? Ich glaube, das waren, was dürften das gewesen sein? 5, 6, 7 Leute. Das war Vau, das war Maku, das war, glaube ich, der kleine Andi Müller-Magun. Der war damals 13 oder 14. Und noch 2, 3 Leute. Also das war alles ziemlich übersichtlich. Und damals sind die ersten, wo man der Datenschleider rausgekommen hat, ich glaube, es gab 2 oder 3 Ausgaben schon. Und ich hatte mir das dann mal angeguckt. Und Vau hatte ja so bestimmte Vorstellungen davon, wie man zum Beispiel sehr ökonomisch, damals musste man ja irgendwie noch wirtschaften. Das heißt, wenn man sowas gedruckt hat, das kostete Geld und man musste Papier sparen und so weiter. Und Vau sagte, okay, wenn man die Buchstaben ganz klein macht, dann kriegt man ganz viel Text irgendwie da drauf. Das heißt, das war reines Augenpulver. Also dir sind irgendwie sofort die Augen ausgefallen. Und du hast schon vom Hinschauen zwei Dioptrien mehr gekriegt. Und ich habe zu ihm, ich habe gesehen, also ich habe zwei Dinge erfasst. Das eine war, da stehen wichtige Sachen drin, die unter die Leute müssen. Das war A und B. Man kann das überhaupt nicht lesen. Und es schaut total kacke aus. Das schaut irgendwie aus wie so ein freilebendes Flugblatt. Und das habe ich Vau gesagt. Und Vau in seiner Art, der nahm das dann immer so auf, murmelte, nickte mit dem Kopf und sagte, okay. Und als er das nächste Mal zu mir kam, hatte er einen Schuhkarton und am Abend, da waren ein paar Zettel drin, ein paar Papiere und Unterlagen, die so zu diesen ersten drei Ausgaben der Datenschläger hatten, das heißt, dieser Schuhkarton war das Datenschlager-Archiv. Und er stellte diesen Schuhkarton bei mir auf den Tisch und sagte, mach du. Und ab dem Moment war ich Chefredakteur der Datenschlager. Und das Fachplatz des der Chaos Computer Club auch seit langer Zeit eben herausgibt. Und das habe ich dann ein paar Jahre gemacht. Und es hat sich dann so ergeben, dass es jeden Donnerstag in meiner Wohnung ein sogenanntes Redaktionstreffen gab, das tatsächlich, wo tatsächlich auch viel für die Datenschläger gemacht worden ist, beraten worden ist. Und das aber im weitesten Sinne auch ein Club-Treffen war.
1984 war ja ein extrem explosives Jahr für den Club. In gewisser Hinsicht würde auch von vielen so als das eigentliche Gründungsjahr des Clubs gesehen, weil einerseits dieser BTX-Hack stattgefunden hat, die Datenschleude erschien und dann Ende des Jahres auch der erste Kongress. Das ist ja alles in dieses Jahr gefallen. Und oah, oah, weil es zu vergesst ist. Genau, wollte ich gerade erwähnen, überrascht ja im Rückblick irgendwie nicht, weil es ja einfach auch das Jahr ist, was sicherlich auch als Zukunftsschau 1981 dazu geführt hat, den Club als solchen auch mit seinem Selbstverständnis zu gründen. Weil es war ja immer schon so, dass es sich eben nicht einfach nur um so eine weitere Technikgruppe gehandelt hat, die jetzt sagt, okay, jetzt machen wir nicht mehr Funk, sondern jetzt machen wir Computer, sondern uns interessiert das ja auch unter einem gesellschaftspolitischen Aspekt. Inwieweit war denn das wahrnehmbar?
Das war vom ersten Augenblick an wahrnehmbar. Das war darin wahrnehmbar, dass der Chaos Computer Club eine Gruppe war, die extrem inkonsistent war von den Leuten her. Aber es gab einen sofort spürbaren Willen dieser vielen verschiedenartigen Charaktere und Leute, die aus unterschiedlichsten Milieus berufen und Interessensbereichen kamen, sich an einen Tisch zu setzen und miteinander gemeinsam in diesem Club zu sein, an einem Tisch zu sitzen, zu reden, was dazu geführt hat. Diese Tradition hält an. Es gibt eine breitartige Diskussionskultur im Chaos Computer Club. Das heißt, da fliegen manchmal die Fetzen. Und es gibt aber auch einen Rahmen. Das bleibt in einem Rahmen. Das wird sozusagen diese Fetzen fliegen. Und dann ist die Diskussion irgendwie gelaufen. Und es gibt dann auch nur Resümee, es gibt dann ein Ergebnis. Und man kommt an einen Punkt. Und es ist sogar so gewesen, dass ich nach einer Weile das Gefühl hatte, dass der Computer als Gerät gar nicht unbedingt anwesend sein muss, sondern dass der Computer als Idee dazu führt, dass diese Menschen, die in der Kneipe niemals wahrscheinlich durch Zufall oder auch nicht an einem Tisch sitzen würden, weil sie einfach zu verschiedenartig sind, dass diese Maschine dazu führt, wie so ein Katalysator, dass diese Leute zusammenkommen und miteinander reden. Und da habe ich quasi diese Idee von Kommunikation auch begriffen, was die Idee dieser Maschine macht. Jetzt gar nicht der Computer selber, also sozusagen im Platten Sinne, dass ich jetzt irgendwie eine E-Mail tippen kann oder so und so, sondern dass diese Idee so stark ist, dass sie so eine katalytische Funktion hat. Dass quasi diese Idee, so ein Konsens ist, wo man sagt, es war zum Beispiel so in den ersten Jahren im Club, ist wenig über Privates gesprochen worden. Man wusste von den meisten Leuten nicht, hat der Vater, hat der Mutter, ist der vom Himmel gefallen. Also woher kommt der, wohin geht der, das war nicht wichtig. Viele Leute hatten Kampfnamen, also die dann im Netz verwendet wurden, Login-Namen oder sonst was. Das hat natürlich auch ein bisschen mit dem Alter zu tun, weil man dann in der Adoleszenz sozusagen ohnehin das Bedürfnis hat, sich mal zu erschaffen oder gar nicht neu zu erschaffen, sondern sich überhaupt mal zu erschaffen und sich als etwas, das man selber prägt und noch mal selber, dem man selber einen Namen gibt oder wo man ganz souveräne Entscheidungen mal im Simulator irgendwie durchführt, da stattfinden zu lassen. Und das heißt, man war in so einer Art sozialen, virtuellen Raum, der aber sehr gut geeignet war, diese verschiedenartigen Leute. Und da waren auch verschiedene Generationen, da waren mindestens drei verschiedene Generationen, also von 13-Jährigen bis zu damals schon Mitteende 30-Jährigen. Das ist schon ein relativ großes Band. Und es waren eigentlich von Anfang an auch Mädels mit dabei, die waren schon in der Minderzahl, aber es gab auch damals schon irgendwie bald Frauen, die aufgetaucht sind, Barbara, Rena und so weiter. Und es war, ohne dass man das jetzt explizit als Komitee hätte einrichten müssen oder in irgendein Programm hätte schreiben müssen, war einfach klar, dass dieser Club sich immer, nicht nur um Computer, sondern immer um Computer plus. Also sozusagen, so wie es gibt in der Chemie dieses Prinzip von Verbindungen und da gibt es sogenannte Valenzen, die die einzelnen Atome halten und da gibt es offene Valenzen. Also es gibt sowas wie Ozon. Das ist sozusagen, eigentlich geht das nicht. Das ist so eine offene Verbindung, die ist ein bisschen instabil. Und im Chaos Computer Club gab es immer sozusagen den Computer als ein Molekül mit offenen Valenzen. Das ist dann ganz starke Anziehungskräfte, wo man sagt, da ist jetzt auch Kultur dran, da ist jetzt auch das gesellschaftliche Umfeld, die politischen Zusammenhänge mit dran. Das heißt, man hat schon geahnt, dass der Computer so eine universelle Idee, Maschinerie ist so eine universelle Metapher, dass man sich nicht damit zufriedengeben kann, zu sagen, das ist jetzt irgendein weiteres elektronisches Gerät wie so ein Amateur-Funkgerät oder so, sondern das ist was, was auch Folgen für die Gesellschaft, Folgen für die Kultur und so weiter haben wird. Und darüber reden wir und daran arbeiten wir mit. Und es gab es einfach vorher überhaupt nicht, diese Betrachtungsweise und dass man diese Dinge miteinander in Zusammenhang machte. Und ich habe eine große Neigung dazu gehabt, weil ich war, wie gesagt, als Schriftsteller. Ich muss jetzt noch einmal zurückgehen. Nach 1979 bin ich nach Düsseldorf gekommen, in der, sozusagen im Morgenroter Punk-Zeit. Das war ein Zufall, das war ein glücklicher Zufall. Und ich war immer mit Musikern zusammen. Ich habe immer mit Musikern zusammen gelebt. Ich habe in einem Studio quasi gewohnt. Das war damals eine Zeit, wo, was dann später mit dem Computer noch einmal passiert ist, quasi Produktionsmittel erstmal erschwinglich wurden für junge Leute. In dem Fall waren das damals Mehrspur-Tonbandgeräte, Vierspur-Tonbandgeräte, die vorher Studiotechnik war, die man für viele 1000 Mark mieten musste. Und es gab Ende der 70er Jahre die ersten von Firmen wie Teac oder so, die ersten Vierspur-Studio-Tonbandgeräte, die man sich kaufen konnte. Die kosteten damals 1000 oder 2000 Mark, nicht ganz genau, aber wir hatten sowas in dem Keller stehen. Und da konntest du einfach eine LP aufnehmen damit. Und das haben wir auch gemacht. In unserem Wohnzimmer sind mehrere Platten aufgenommen, waren unter Ranten, immer Musiker ein und aus. Und ich hab's als Schriftsteller ein bisschen schwer gehabt und hab das aber immer auch als Herausforderung empfunden, weil man eigentlich dieser Produktionsgeschwindigkeit, die damals durch diese Produktionsmittel auch da war, das heißt, man hatte eine Idee, man hat gesagt, okay, lass uns irgendwie ein paar Stücke aufnehmen. Und dann haben wir auch mal gemacht. Dann setzt du dich aus Schnack hin, nimmst ein paar Stücke auf. Aber wir haben irgendwann mal zum Spaß, das war ja damals irgendwie eher peinlich, dass man früher mal lange Haare hatte und immer Folkmusik gehört hat. Und dann haben wir quasi, als wir mal so unter uns waren, Freunde von mir, Thomas Schwebel und Peter Hain, Janie, der Sänger der Fellfarben, bekannte Gruppe, saßen wir zusammen und haben uns sozusagen alle geoutet, dass wir alle mal Bob Dylan und Leonard Cohen gehört haben und so. Und dann fing Xao, der noch mit dabei saß, an, ein Punkstück zu spielen, auf der Akustischen Gitarre natürlich. Und wir haben, nee, Quatsch, irgendeine Cohen-Melodie und wir haben den Text von irgendeinem Punk-Song, von einem Deutschen, draufgespielt und das war so komisch, das passte. Dann haben wir noch eins probiert und haben uns kaputt gelacht. Und dann ist Xao irgendwann mal zu dem Vierspur-Band gegangen und hat das eingeschaltet und wir haben einfach weiter Spaß gehabt. Nur das Band lief mit, am nächsten Tag kam Jenny noch mal mit einer Plastiktüte, in der war ein Kasus und Röti und ein kleines grünes Plastik-Saxophon aus einem Kaugummi-Automat. Das heißt, damit haben wir das Arrangement aufgespielt auf einem von den vier Spuren und dann sagte Xao, wir könnten das Band dann Alfred Hilsberg nach Hamburg schicken bei Rip-Off Records, der Alfred irgendwie dieses Rip-Off-Label hatte. Dann haben wir das Band da hingeschickt und Alfred hatte, wie der Zufall so will, eine historisch wertvolle Aufnahme aus irgendeinem Konzert aus dem Ratinger Hof in Düsseldorf, wo Leute, die dann später alle berühmt geworden sind, Gaby Delgado von der Gruppe TAF, Deutsche Amerikanische Freundschaft, und Markus Öhlen, der als Maler dann Furore gemacht hat und vorher gelegentlich im Ratinger Hof dem Punk-Hauptquartier in Unterhosen auf dem Tisch stand und ein Würstchen in den Ventilator gehalten hat an der Decke und so weiter. Und da hatte Alfred irgendwie von so einer Art All-Stars-Band, die dann so eine 15-Minuten-Version von ein Loch ist im Eimer und es sprach der alte Haukling der Indianer. Jedenfalls, das war für eine LP zu wenig. Das war aber für eine Seite von einer LP reichte das gerade. Und das Material, das wir geliefert haben, reichte auch gerade für eine halbe LP-Seite. Also sagte Alfred, toll, wir machen da eine LP draus. Das heißt, wir haben so eine Art LP-Sharing gemacht. Also wir hatten die beiden Stücke oder die beiden Aufnahmen hatten überhaupt nichts miteinander zu tun, außer dass sie gerade eine halbe LP lang waren. Für einen Maxi war es zu viel und für eine ganze LP zu wenig. Also haben wir eine LP gemacht, wo sozusagen die eine Hälfte völlig was anderes als die andere Hälfte war. Und das ist innerhalb von drei Wochen passiert. Und da saß ich als Schriftsteller daneben und habe mit den Ohren gewackelt, weil so schnell konnte ich nicht produzieren. Ich saß mit meiner elektrischen Schreibmaschine da und während ich da so vor mich hingedichtet habe und wusste, wenn ich jetzt ein Buch schreibe, dann dauert das mindestens ein halbes, dreiviertel Jahr, bis das rauskommt, bin ich von den Musikern, wie soll ich sagen, mit Respekt behandelt worden. Man hat schon gemerkt, dass Literatur war damals extrem unhip. Das war ein bisschen so wie in den Micky-Maus-Heften helfen die Pfadfinder immer so älteren Damen über die Straße. Und so wie diese ältere Dame war, so dieses Gefühl, also so, ich bin toleriert worden von den Punks und das rechne ich mir schon hoch an.
Wo sitzt denn da jetzt die, siehst du da eine Parallele? Also jetzt war jetzt so ein Einblick in Musikkultur, die ja jetzt so mit der Hacker-Szene ja nicht unmittelbar was zu tun hat.
Na doch, jetzt kommt mir mit dem Computer ins Spiel. Und zwar als ich dann bei meinem Freund mit dem Motorrad und mit der KZ Chomsky war und mir dann so schnell als möglich vom Munde abgespart auch einen Computer besorgt habe, ich hatte sofort begriffen, auch als ich diesen Computer bei meinem Freund Matthias da gesehen habe, das ist eine Schreibmaschine, mit der man auch Lärm machen kann. Und sowas gab es vorher noch nie. Lärm? Ja, immer Lärm. Man konnte damit Synthesizer, also man konnte dieses Gerät zum Quicken bringen. Und es war beeindruckend. Es hatte so einen Mythos, der Computer hatte einen Mythos. Wenn ich sage, ich habe eine Schreibmaschine, dann, ich weiß noch, dass dann welche von den von den Musikern, die kamen dann irgendwie so, eine Schreibmaschine. Ich hatte dann manchmal das Gefühl, ich habe da so einen Ammoniten irgendwie auf dem Schreibtisch liegen oder so. Aber ein Computer, das war irgendwie so ein respektgebietendes Ding. Ich war ja, die Musiker hatten ja damals eine Menge elektronische Geräte, Synthesizer und Sequencer, so diese alten analogen Sequencer, die aussahen wie so Telefonvermittlungszentralen aus den 20er-Jahren mit so Steckkabeln. Und ich war natürlich immer furchtbar neidisch als Autor. Und dann hatte ich diesen Computer und damit hatte ich quasi, also was die Bewaffnung an ging und die optische Attraktion, auch was zu bieten. Und ich hab als mein erstes Buch rausgekommen, ist auch eine Lesereise mit dem Niklas Stiller, meinem Partner, mit dem ich zusammen mein erstes Buch geschrieben hab gemacht. Und ich bin auch der erste Autor gewesen, der mit dem, ich hab meinen Computer mit auf die Bühne genommen. Und für mich war auch diese Welten, die scheinbar nicht zusammengehören. Und da kommt jetzt der Chaos Computer Club sozusagen auch wieder, ohne dass ich es damals noch wusste, schon ins Spiel. Ich hab dann gelesen aus dem Buch. Ich hab sozusagen Poesie vorgelesen und hab im Hintergrund, ich hatte dann die Veranstalter immer gebeten, ein Videoprojekt oder so ein Beamer zu organisieren. Das war damals noch am Rande des Klaviertransports. Das war dann ziemlich aufwendig. Da mussten immer vier Mann kommen. Und die waren immer so integriert. Das waren also so Möbel, da war alles, die Leinwand und der Projekt war und alles. Und dann hatte man da so einen Teil und dann wurde mein, das war mein C64, hatte ja so einen RGB-Ausgang, mit dem man in den Fernseher rein konnte und damit auch in diesen Beamer. Und dann konnte man das da darstellen. Video-Ausgang. Und ich hatte für diese Lesereise so zwei, drei kleine Basic-Programme geschrieben, einen Vorspann, der ein bisschen eine Parodie von dem Kinovorspann war. Ich wollte sozusagen als Autor so einen Hollywood-artigen Auftritt haben. Da war dann auch sehr dramatische Musik.
Das heißt, die Poetronik-Geschichte?
Genau, genau. Das war diese Lesung, also sozusagen diese... Ich habe das dann... Also diese Lesereise war sozusagen das allererste Mal. Und da gab es hier in Berlin einen Auftritt. Damals hieß das Loft, heute heißt das Goya, ist schon wieder Pleite irgendwie so. Und da hatten wir einen Auftritt im Loft. Wir waren zusammen... Ist das nicht Metropol? Ja, genau, Metropol. Und im Metropol gab es sozusagen eine Untereinheit, also ein Unterveranstaltungsort, das Loft, im Metropol. Genau. Wir waren mit einer Stuttgarter Punkband zusammen auf Tour. Die hieß Zimt querstrich Autofick. Und so war das damals. Und dann sind wir da aufgetreten. Und ich hatte irgendwie unterschätzt, dass die Musiker mit ihrem Equipment eine ziemlich starke elektronische Streustrahlung verursachen. Wusste ich alles nicht. Und dann saß ich da. Und wir waren ohnehin schon spät. Das heißt, wir waren so spät, dass im Publikum bereits die Rufe Anfang an Anfang an verklungen waren. Und die ersten Leute riefen bereits aufhören. Und wir wussten, okay, wir müssen jetzt anfangen, weil sonst gehen die einfach oder werfen mit vollen Bierdosen. Und dann fingen wir an und mein Computer ging nicht. Das heißt, der C64, alles, was der machte, er machte einen blauen Bildschirm, darauf blinkte ein Cursor. Und unter dem blinkenden Cursor stand Syntax-Error. Das war alles, was aus dem Gerät rauszukriegen war. Und ich hatte eine Todespanik, weil ich irgendwie diesen ganzen Aufwand und diesen ganzen Beamer und dieses ganze Programmieren usw. Und das Verrückte war, die Leute waren zufrieden, weil die wussten, das ist das mythische Gerät. Das ist sozusagen das authentische Ding. Dieser blaue Schirm, dieser blinkende Cursor. Und da sitzt Glaser vor diesen Broadkasten, vor diesem Bejen. Und das ist ein richtiger echter Computer. Das heißt, ich habe nicht einfach... Der Heiland. Genau, der Heiland. Nein, ich bin nicht euer Heiland. Nur der wahre Heiland verleugnet sich selbst. Heiland, Heiland. Und es war einfach so, dass ich dann gemerkt habe, die Leute saßen vor diesem blauen Schirm und haben nach und haben Richtung Osten gebetet. Und waren es zufrieden. Ich bin wirklich erstaunt gewesen. Und ich war auch ziemlich glücklich, dass das einfach... Das war sehr Zen-Buddhistisch. Und es gab dann noch einen zweiten Teil. Also wenn es funktioniert hat, war das so. Da kam dieser dramatische Hollywood-artige Vorspann. Dann war eben statt Jazz und Lyrik gab es in den 70er Jahren. Wir haben dann eben Punk und Prosa gemacht. Und dann gab es noch einen zweiten Teil, den ich vom Computer eingespielt habe, nämlich eine automatisierte Diskussion nach der Lesung. Jetzt muss man noch dazu wissen, dass Graz, wo ich herkomme, so was wie das Adlerhorst der deutschsprachigen Gegenwartsliteratur so in den 60er, 70er Jahren war. Da gab es die Grazer Autorenversammlung, das vor dem Stadtpark. Und das heißt, ich habe als etwas nicht mehr ganz so kleiner Junge eine ziemliche Menge an Autorenlesungen und Autorinnenlesungen mitverfolgt und habe zum Teil Leute, also ich habe einfach gesehen, dass es da bestimmte Strukturen gibt, die sich wiederholen und habe mir dann gesagt, okay, das kann man algorithmisieren. Herr Glaser, wo ist denn der sozio-politische Hintergrund bei Ihren Arbeiten und so? Also solche Fragen, da gab es ein paar lustige Antworten drauf und so weiter und das kam auch immer ganz gut und ich habe das dann später weitergetrieben und diese Lesungen so weit automatisiert, dass ich mich selber wegrationalisiert habe. Das heißt, es gab dann einige Lesungen, wenn mich jemand zu einer Lesung eingeladen hat, habe ich eine Diskette, also es gab so ein Pack, so ein Kit sozusagen. Das hieß Poetronic. Das bestand aus einer Audiokassette, einer Diskette oder zwei Disketten für den C64 und einer Bedienungsanleitung für einen Operator. Und es musste dann ein C64, eine Projektionseinrichtung und ein Operator, der mich sozusagen vertreten hat oder der mich in Betrieb gesetzt hat, dort engagiert werden. Und es ist mir berichtet worden aus Kassel, aus Wien, aus einigen Städten, dass diese Lesungen mit relativ großem Erfolg stattgefunden haben. Sowas kann man natürlich nicht ewig machen, aber ich habe das dann bis in die letzte Konsequenz durchgeführt.
Das heißt, du warst sozusagen ein bisschen der Stell-Arc des Literatur-Maschinen, der von der Maschine ferngesteuert war.
Ich habe zwar keine Lesungen aus meinem Magen heraus veranstaltet. Stell-Arc hat ja mal eine Ausstellung in seinem Magen gemacht, ein Kunstobjekt, verschluckt.
Der Typ ist echt hardcore. Lass uns das jetzt an der Stelle nicht vertiefen, weil ich möchte gerne nochmal den Bogen natürlich wieder zurückspannen auf den Club 84. Wann bist du denn eigentlich dazu gestoßen? Hast du das mit dem BTX Hack dann auch live mitbekommen? Ist natürlich jetzt so eine häufig kolportierte Geschichte, aber vielleicht sollte man trotzdem nochmal rübergehen. Kurz gesagt, der Club hat einen Weg gefunden, das BTX-System so weit auszutricksen, eine Kennung herauszubekommen und der Hamburger Stadt Sparkasse quasi über den Umweg des Betrachtens kostenpflichtiger CCC-Angebotsseiten im BTX 100.000 Mark zu entrollen. 130.000 oder 136.000 Mark. Eine nicht unerhebliche Summe. Auf jeden Fall ein Betrag, den jeder schon ein bisschen unter der Kategorie Bankraub abbruchen würde. So wurde es in der Öffentlichkeit auch wahrgenommen, auch wenn das de facto so nicht war. Aber diese Kombination, die Robin Hoods, die jetzt aus dem Datenwald kommen, die die Bank überfallen und der Öffentlichkeit zeigen, dass es alles ganz böse ist. Das Geld wurde ja dann quasi nie wirklich bezogen, sondern bevor überhaupt jemand die Gelegenheit hatte, das zur Kenntnis zu nehmen, war es ja schon in der Presse. Was mich interessieren würde, ist, wie sich die Wahrnehmung dieser doch bis dahin wahrscheinlich sehr unbekannten Subkultur in der Öffentlichkeit gewandelt hat. Also da sind ja sowohl die Öffentlichkeit, als auch der Club selber durch so einen Prozess durchgegangen.
Zwei Dinge. Das eine war, dass damit, da muss man schon nochmal was dazu sagen, nämlich dass das alles gleich in der Zeitung stand und dass der Chaos Computer Club nicht mit dieser Kohle und am Abend nach Brasilien ausgewandert ist. Das hat sich als eine bis heute extrem erfolgreiche Strategie herausgestellt, Schutz in der Öffentlichkeit zu suchen. Respektive Informationen, über die man auf ungewöhnliche Weise, nämlich durch Haken gewonnen hat, an die Öffentlichkeit zu bringen, in einer aufklärerischen Absicht. Das ist jetzt etwas pädagogisch wertvoll formuliert. Das ist aber auch in später eingetretenen, sehr kritischen Situationen letzten Endes immer ein extrem positives Modell, eine extrem positive Strategie, weil man so will, des Chaos Computer Clubs gewesen ist. Also wo sich auch Form und Inhalt entsprechen, dass Information verbreitet werden muss und soll, dass es keine Geheimnisse geben darf. Also diese Utopien, dass man die versucht, für sich selbst möglichst konsequent umzusetzen, dass man sagt, wir haben jetzt nicht irgendein kleines Geheimwissen und wir gehen zur Hamburger Sparkasse und sagen, ich weiß was, ich erpresse dich oder ich verrat's und ich kriege dann den Orden oder sonst irgendwas. Sondern der Club hat gesagt, okay, die Post sagt, BTX ist sicher. Das haben sie ja auch noch nach dem BTX-Sack irgendwie unterstrichen. Das ist ja irgendwie immer ein großer Lacher gewesen. Und das ist für beide, das ist das, was man heute so schön eine Win-win-Situation nennt, weil es im Grunde genommen für beide Seiten ein Gewinn war. Der Chaos Computer Club ist durch diesen BTX-Sack bekannt geworden. Und damit die ganzen Dinge, die uns im Club interessiert haben. Computer, die Unsicherheit von Computern, Begriffe wie Datenschutz sind zum ersten Mal in der öffentlichen Diskussion aufgetaucht. Das gab es vorher einfach nicht. Und auf der anderen Seite kann sich die Post, die es damals noch gab, die Post, die das Monopol auf diese ganzen Kommunikationsdinge hatte. Dadurch wurde BTX, Bildschirmtext, was die Abkürzung BTX ja bedeutete, plötzlich richtig bekannt. Vorher war das nämlich gar nicht so. Die haben zwar eine Menge Werbung dafür gemacht. Ich bin ja vorher in Düsseldorf gewesen. Interessanterweise ist damals in Düsseldorf und in Hamburg haben diese BTX-Feldversuche stattgefunden. Und ich habe, was ja diese Zeit Ende der 70er, Anfang der 80er Jahre mitgeprägt hat, war, es war die Gründerzeit der Stadtzeitungen. Das heißt, da gab es zum ersten Mal in Deutschland, in jeder größeren Stadt, eine Stadtzeitung. Später zwei, manches Mal sogar drei. Aber das sind überall, und ich habe für die damalige Stadtzeitung in Düsseldorf den Überblick zuerst als Komposersetzer gearbeitet, an einer Maschine, die sozusagen am Übergang zum Computerzeitalter stand. Ohne dass es mir bewusst gewesen wäre, war das eigentlich der erste Computer, an dem ich gearbeitet habe. Das war eine IBM Kugelkopfschreibmaschine mit 8000 Zeichenspeichern, was im Grunde genommen schon ein Computer war. Und habe dann, weil diese frisch gegründeten Zeitungen noch mit relativ flachen Hierarchien gearbeitet haben, da konnte einfach jeder, der an einer Redaktionskonferenz teilgenommen hat, eine gute Idee bringen. Und wenn alle die Idee gut fanden, dann hieß es, mach mal. Und dann habe ich irgendwie Geschichten geschrieben. Beziehungsweise, ich bin dummerweise, habe ich bemerkt, wenn ich eine Idee äußere, dann hieß es, mach mal. Und dann merkte ich plötzlich, ich wollte eigentlich nur diese Idee sozusagen in den Raum werfen. Dann merkte ich plötzlich, ah scheiße, das bleibt an mir hängen. Jetzt muss ich das machen. Und eine der ersten Geschichten, die ich geschrieben habe, war über den BTX-Feldversuch in Düsseldorf. Das heißt, ich habe dann eine richtige kleine Reportage darüber gemacht, zu Leuten, die dann so eine Tastatur und so einen BTX-tauglichen Fernseher von der Firma Löwe, das musste man sich nämlich für teures Geld noch alles dazukaufen, bekommen haben und die mir im Grunde genommen, wie so Leserbriefschreiber so diese ganze PR, diesen ganzen PR-Müll, den die Post verbreitet hat, nochmal nacherzählt haben, wie wunderbar das alles sein wird und dass sie irgendwie ihre Reisen buchen werden bei BTX und so weiter.
Wie hat denn jetzt diese BTX-Geschichte den Club selber verändert? Ich meine, du hast ihn dann vorher kennengelernt und dann brach auf einmal das Medieninferno über den Club herein, den er, wie ich mal vermute, noch halbwegs elegant abgefedert hat?
Auch das ist etwas, was im Club jeder relativ schnell gelernt hat. Und da war Vau und da war auch Steffen Vernieri mit dem Vau. Damals, sagen wir mal, in einer Brüderschaft im Geiste oder in so einer engen Partnerschaft, die haben ja gemeinsam diesen BTX Hack gemacht. Die beiden haben immer, und vor allem Vau, das muss man schon hervorheben, jeden, der im Club aufgetaucht ist, beigebracht. Und zwar jetzt nicht explizit, sondern das ergab sich einfach so, wie man mit den Medien umgeht, wie man Dinge prägnant formulieren kann, wenn dir irgendein Mikro vor die Nase hält, wie du in drei Sätzen, also wie du sozusagen diese Bedürfnisse, die die Medien einem entgegenbringen, so bedienen kannst, dass unsere Ideen möglichst deutlich gemacht werden, möglichst kompakt und möglichst verständlich rübergebracht werden. Also das war eine sehr anspruchsvolle Aufgabe, war natürlich auch nicht jeder gewillt, sozusagen da einzusteigen, weil es im Club immer, was auch sehr gut war, verschiedene Fraktionen gab. Es gab zum Beispiel die Techniker, also die Hardcore-Techniker, die in Hardcore-Technikersprache gesprochen haben und nicht bereit waren, ein allgemein verständliches Deutsch zu sprechen. Und es gab aber Leute, und da war immer auch ein wirklich großes Vorbild, das kann man einfach so sagen, in dem er beides zugleich war. Wau wusste von der Technik sehr viel bis ins Detail, er kannte sich wirklich gut aus, er kannte sozusagen die Bets beim Namen und war aber auch jemand, der dann die Abstraktionen, die Ideen, die Dinge, die wichtig sind, auf so ganz prägnante Formeln wie Kabelsalat und so weiter bringen konnte. Was passiert ist, ist, dass der Chaos Computer Club auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise in bestimmten Dingen Definitionsvorgaben oder Definitionshoheiten für sich beansprucht hat und gesagt hat, da sind neue Welten, da eröffnen sich neue Perspektiven und wir schlagen ein paar Bezeichnungen dafür vor oder wir schlagen ein paar Beschreibungsmöglichkeiten für diese Dinge vor. Und es gab vorher einfach nichts, da gab es nur so die klassische technokratische Sicht der Welt. Irgendwie, ja, das ist Technik und das ist deutsche Technik und das muss funktionieren und so kam die Post immer. Und dann kamen wir und haben immer so ein fröhliches Liedchen gesungen. Wir lagen vor Madagaskar und hatten die Post an Bord und haben gezeigt, also es ist zum Beispiel auch, das war übrigens auch was, wo ich gesehen habe, dass das eine ganz besondere Gruppe ist, weil Technik und Humor, das gab es davor eigentlich nicht. Also es gab zwar einen Ingenieur Düsendrieb in den Mickey-Maus-Häften, aber irgendwie so Techniker und Humor, das war vorher nicht richtig kompatibel gewesen. Und worauf das mich hingewiesen hat war...
Ich würde sogar sagen Technik und Spaß.
Absolut, absolut. Also das hat ja beim Hacken im Kronen genommen immer eine ganz große Rolle gespielt.
Genau, der Spaß am Gerät ist ja auch so ein Slogan, der sich so später festgesetzt hat.
Genau, und das ist ja so eine Art, wie soll ich sagen, eine Grußform im Chaos Computer Club in der Zwischenzeit geworden. Viel Spaß am Gerät und das ist ja auch so, wie bei der Olympiade irgendwie die Spiele sind eröffnet, wenn der Chaos Communication Congress, der ja auch eine große Tradition hat und in der Zwischenzeit eine sehr große renommierliche Veranstaltung geworden ist, eröffnet wird, dann wird das mit den Worten viel Spaß am Gerät. Und was Humor immer bedeutet, ist, dass ein bisschen zu viel Energie da ist. Und zwar das ist im positiven Sinne. Es ist sozusagen nicht einfach nur genug Energie da, sondern nochmal ein bisschen mehr. Es ist ein Überschuss da. Es ist ein kreativer Überschuss, ein Überschuss an Ideen, ein Überschuss an Souveränität, wenn man so will. Und das war auch etwas ganz... Also es gibt ja in Deutschland eine Tradition von eine gewisse, sagen wir es mal polemisch, der Deutsche neigt zum Apokalyptischen. Das ist so etwas Wagnerianisches. Der Deutsche liebt so die Gedanken, die so in Dunkelheit und Weltuntergang gehen. Und zwar, meiner Meinung nach, ist das eine bestimmte Form von Eitelkeit. Weil, du kannst dich natürlich selber erhöhen, indem du sagst, ja, die Welt ist untergegangen, aber ich war dabei. Und jetzt ist es so, dass es dann natürlich eine bestimmte Spezialform gibt. Das kann man sich ja auch zum Beruf machen. So eine Haltung in Form von zum Beispiel Kulturpessimismus. Also, dass du sagst, Fernsehen macht dumm, Maschinen sind böse, nur Menschen, die irgendwie im Grase sitzen und an den Blumen riechen und Goethe lesen sind gut und Kulturwesen und so weiter. Und jeder, der irgendwie mit einem technischen Gerät in Berührung kommt, ist entweder irgendwie, soll man Mondraketen bauen oder Turbinen oder es ist irgendwie ganz böse und schlecht. Jedenfalls gibt es, das hat natürlich mit der speziellen deutschen Vergangenheit, mit der Nazizeit und mit dieser Propagandamaschine, die Goebbels damals betrieben hat, und mit dem dazugehörigen kleinen Volksempfänger zu tun, dass jedes Medium in der Nachkriegszeit sofort im Verdacht stand, wiederum als ein propagandistisches und manipulatives Medium eingesetzt zu werden. Da war so ein nicht unberechtigtes Misstrauen in Deutschland, was ein speziell deutsches Phänomen ist. Und es gab dann in den 50er-, 60er-Jahren so eine Haltung. Es gibt einen Amerikaner, der...
Das gibt es aber auch heute noch.
Ich höre ja, das hat nicht lange Tradition.
Ich erinnere da nur an die RFID-Diskussion.
Okay, es gab damals ein Buch, das ist 1957 rausgekommen, Vance Packard, Hidden Persuaders, die stillen Heimliche Verführer. Ich glaube, Heimliche Verführer hieß das auf Deutsch. Im Grunde genommen, wo es darum ging, es geht in dem Buch hauptsächlich um Werbung und Manipulation, wo jedenfalls ein Menschenbild geprägt worden ist, das uns alle, also sozusagen zu von technischen Medien geknächteten Opfern macht. Also quasi so, wir sind so Zombies, die von außen, wo von außen wird, an unseren Schnürchen gezogen. Und wir sind dumme Marionetten und Rennern. Immer sofort los, nachdem wir einen Kaugummi- Werbespot gesehen haben, wollen wir sofort einen Kaugummi haben. Und dann ist aber in den 70er Jahren die Fernseher-Fernbedienung erfunden worden und es hat sich herausgestellt, dass diese Zombies noch in der Lage sind, verhältnismäßig souveränes Verhalten an den Tag zu legen. Und dann hat sich gezeigt, dass also sozusagen im Zusammenhang mit technischen Medien ein anderes Menschenbild möglich ist. Also mit dem Aufkommen, also da war das Privatfernsehen und so weiter, da hat man ja dann gesehen, dass die ganzen Werbeleute von nichts mehr Angst und Respekt haben als vor dem Individuum, vor dem Couch-Potato mit seiner Fernbedienung. Und parallel dazu ist die PC-Revolution losgegangen und da waren dann so kleine Maschinen, mit denen man plötzlich nicht nur irgendwie sein eigenes, sozusagen so 30 Fernsehprogramme durchschalten konnte, sondern im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes eigene Programme schreiben konnte, machen konnte. Und da ging dann plötzlich so eine ganz andere und im Chaos Computer Club war dieses Gefühl von vornherein zu Hause, wir sind souverän und hier ist eine Maschine und wir gucken uns die jetzt mal an. Und zwar nicht in dieser noch ein historischer Rückgriff, es gab in die jüngere Vergangenheit und zwar die RAF-Terrorismus Hysterie in Deutschland in den 70er Jahren, die dann in dem sogenannten deutschen Herbst, wann war denn das? 77, 78, diese ganzen schrecklichen Dinge, Schleier und so weiter, gipfelte und Herold, der damalige PK-Chef mit der Rasterverhandlung. Und dieser Begriff war quasi, der verkoppelte sich so mit Orwell und 1984 für die gesamte deutsche Linke, war damit praktisch der Computer ein Instrument des Teufels. Und es gab dann zwei ganz unterschiedliche Entwicklungslinien, nämlich in Amerika ist dieses Gerät viel schneller von den Alternativen, die sogenannte Grassroot- Bewegung, aufgenommen worden. Die haben viel schneller begriffen, wir haben hier eine Möglichkeit, ein unabhängiges, schwer oder nicht zensurierbares, eigenes Kommunikationssystem aufzubauen, ein eigenes Medium aufzubauen, Stichwort Feedonet und so weiter.
Oder The Well.
Oder The Well, genau. Die gibt es ja immer noch, das ist ja wirklich ein Meilenstein, was da passiert ist. Und jedenfalls diese Dinge haben sie in Amerika. Also da haben sozusagen Menschen, die auf dem Lande lebten, auf irgendwelchen alternativen Bauernhöfen, ohne zu zögern Computer angeschafft, werden gesagt, das ist gut für uns. Das ist interessant, das machen wir jetzt. Während ich mich noch erinnere, noch in der ersten Hälfte der 80er Jahre Ausgaben zum Beispiel von Konkret aufgeschlagen habe, wo Texte drin standen, die sich mit Computern beschäftigt haben, wo man das Gefühl hatte, die gehen so ähnlich mit Computern um wie Löwenbändige, indem die so einen Stuhl vor sich halten oder die nähern sich diesem Gerät nur mit langen Stangen irgendwie und berühren das so aus zwei Meter Entfernung. Also so war die Haltung. Und Benny Herrlin, der bei den frisch gegründeten Grünen damals war, mit der mich mit Vau bekannt gemacht hat, hat mir erzählt, er war einer der Allerersten bei den Grünen, der einen Computer besessen hat. Und in den ersten Jahren bei den Grünen, also in der Anfangszeit, würde ich jetzt mal sagen, war das so, dass die Computerbesitzer bei den Grünen noch eine Art konspirative Gemeinschaft waren. Das heißt, bei Parteitreffen gab es manchmal so Murmelecken irgendwie in den Pausen, wo man sich an irgendwas erkannte oder sozusagen so eine Bemerkung fallen lassen hat, aus der andere schließen konnten, aha, der hat irgendwie was mit Computer zu tun. Und dann kam, sagte der eine, du, so hinter vorgehalten, ich habe auch einen Computer und ich habe eine Software und so, und dann geht es so. Das klingt so ein bisschen wie so eine Schwulenvereinigung. Genau, genau, das war schlimm. Damals war es schlimmer, weil das eben herrollt, rasterfernfahren. Und du warst mit dem Computer im Reich des Bösen. Also du hast ein satanisches Objekt. Das war eine lange Zeit, also diese panische Angst vor der Steckdose hat die deutsche Linke technologisch oder in der ganzen Technologie-Diskussion und in der gesellschaftlichen Auseinandersetzung, die diese Technologie dann zur Folge gehabt hat, zurückgeworfen. Es gab ja eine Studie, die der Chaos Computer Club für die Grünen dann, also im Auftrage der Grünen ausgeführt hat, die sich damit mit der Frage beschäftigt hat, wie weit digitale Informationstechnik für die, ich glaube für die, ich weiß nicht, ob für die Grünen insgesamt oder für die Bundestagsfraktion der Grünen, die waren damals schon gewählt worden.
Ich glaube, es war sogar die Bundestagsfraktion.
Genau, also wie weit das für die von Nutzen ist. Und diese Studie des Chaos Computer Clubs ist zu dem Schluss gekommen, die Grünen sollen es bleiben lassen, weil die sich einfach sonst zu sehr die Köpfe einhauen, weil das sozusagen, weil sich herausgestellt hat, es wäre, die Technik per se wäre schon nützlich, aber sozusagen die ganze ideologische Debatte, die da dran hing, war bei Weitem noch nicht geführt und ausgestanden und hätte also kontraproduktive Effekte gehabt. Weswegen die Studie zu dem Schluss gekommen ist, die Grünen sollen es erstmal lieber bleiben lassen und weiter in Steintafeln ritzen, also und auf Lämtäfelchen kleine Kreuze machen.
Ja, mir fällt dazu ein, dieses Schlagwort, auch so ein Thema, was auch der Club so über die Jahre auch immer wieder weiterentwickelt hat, die Grundthese Chancen und Risiken, dass man sozusagen Technologie nicht per se als gut oder schlecht einordnen kann, sondern dass eben über das Verstehen der Materie und der Zusammenhänge letztlich die eigene Erkenntnis schärft, ob es sich hierbei jetzt um etwas Nützliches handelt oder um etwas Schädliches im Kontext natürlich der Anwendung. Also man muss halt schauen, wie will man das einsetzen. Computer an sich können dich irgendwie befreien und können dir irgendwie das Schreiben vereinfachen und können deine Kreativität freien Lauf lassen, aber auf der anderen Seite will man eben die Maschine an bestimmten Stellen nicht haben. Da spielt ja auch diese Hacker-Ethik eine Rolle. Das ist ja auch Anfang der 80er Jahre aufgekommen, dieser Begriff. Wann bist du da das erste Mal in Zusammenhang gekommen mit?
Ziemlich früh. Also das schwebt immer so im Raume, dass es eine bestimmte Grundhaltung gibt, dass es eine gewisse technische Virtuosität gibt, die entfaltet wird und dass zu dieser technischen Virtuosität so eine gewisse, wie soll ich sagen, so eine Art Vandalismus- Boykott schon mal, also dass Vandalismus einfach unelegant ist. Vandalismus ist absolut uncool. Es gab zum Beispiel damals, also ich habe die frühen Hackereien, an denen ich teilgenommen habe, wobei ich sagen muss, ich bin immer sehr privilegiert gewesen, das heißt, ich habe von der Technik, das war damals unumgänglich, einiges verstanden, ich bin aber kein ausgesprochen guter Techniker, sondern ich bin immer eher ein Beobachter gewesen und ich bin aber immer mit Leuten aus dem Club eng befreundet gewesen, die ausgesprochene Virtuosen waren und es gab dann so eine Pilot- und Kopilotensituation oft, wo ich sozusagen auf einem Kopilotensitz sitzen konnte und einen Virtuosen mit einem großen Verständnis auch der technischen Dinge, die er da vollzogen hat, beobachten konnte und dann noch meine eigenen Vorschläge und Ideen einbringen konnte, die er dann eben umsetzen konnte, das hat sich gegenseitig Ich glaube, wir haben uns gegenseitig so befruchtet. Wir hatten uns etwas einfacher zu sagen, eine Menge Spaß immer miteinander. Und da gab es so Dinge, ich erinnere mich mal, dass wir im Rechner oder im Rechenzimmer, also in irgendeinem Computer von irgendeiner Bank waren. So, das hört sich jetzt alles spannend und halb kriminell an, war aber völlig harmlos, weil das einfach ein Weg in einem Netz war, den wir erkundet haben. Das ist so, wie wenn du irgendwie in einer neuen Stadt bist und versuchst diese Stadt kennenzulernen und läufst mal irgendwie erst mal nach Norden, dann nach Süden, dann nach Westen, dann nach Osten. Dann waren wir in dieser Bank gelandet. Und mein Freund Vic, mit dem ich diese Reisen damals oft gemeinsam unternommen habe, der hat dort in diesem Rechner eine Verbindungsmöglichkeit entdeckt, von der er nicht wusste, wohin die führt und was passiert, wenn man diese Verbindung jetzt benutzt. Und hat, um das so zu erkundigen, mal so ein Klingelsignal reingesetzt, so ein Ping reingeschickt und geguckt, was passiert. Und es hat sich herausgestellt dann, dass das eine Alarmverbindung zu einer Filiale der Bank in Sydney war und dass dort in Sydney irgendwie so ein rotes Lämpchen losgegangen sein muss. Und innerhalb kürzester Zeit, innerhalb von einer halben Minute oder so, wir irgendwie eine Antwort hatten. Also da richtig jemand zu uns gesprochen hat, was ist da los und so. Das fand alles in Form von Buchstaben am Bildschirm statt, um das jetzt wieder ein bisschen zu relativieren. Und das Ausschlaggebende war, dass wir damals nicht abgeschaltet haben, als sich da jemand gemeldet hat, sondern mit dem geredet haben. Das war einfach Konsens, das macht man nicht. Also wir haben damit zum Ausdruck gebracht, dass wir nichts Falsches machen und nichts Böses vorhaben, indem wir einfach uns mit den Leuten unterhalten haben. Wir haben einfach geredet miteinander, da hing irgendein Operator dran, der sagte, was macht ihr da? Wer seid ihr? Was ist los? Und wir haben gesagt, wir gucken irgendwie so, wir machen hier nichts Böses. Und das hat er uns auch abgekauft. Und ich kann mich erinnern, dass wir uns verabredet haben. Und es war auch nicht so, dass der uns dann irgendwie die Polizei auf den Hals hetzen wollte oder so. Wir haben uns dann nochmal getroffen. Und es war dann auch immer ein bisschen so, dass die natürlich von uns Informationen haben wollten, wie wir da reingekommen sind und so weiter und so fort. Und das Letzte ist, es ist auch vorgekommen, dass sich jemand bei uns bedankt hat und sagte, also es ist letztendlich so, dass dadurch, dass ihr hier reingekommen seid, wir unsere Sicherheitsmaßnahmen nochmal überdacht haben. Und das ganze jetzt, das ganze System jetzt, also etwas unsere Sicherheitsmaßnahmen umgestellt haben.
Hackerethik, das war sozusagen Hackerethik on the road.
Das war sozusagen ohne Programm. Das war die Art und Weise, wie wir einfach aus unserer Erziehung heraus, aus dem, wenn du aus einer wirklichen Welt, in der du sozusagen auf die Finger geklopft, also die Leute, die damals gehackt haben, hätten im Supermarkt keinen Kaugummi geklaut. Und mit dieser Haltung ist man aber in eine Welt reingegangen, die, muss man jetzt dazu sagen, gemacht worden ist, weil sie moralfrei ist. Und zwar muss man jetzt ein bisschen zurückgreifen und sagen, der Computer ist entstanden aus militärischen Bedürfnissen, der Computer ist im zweiten Weltkrieg. Also ich sehe jetzt mal ab von Leuten wie Konrad Zuse, die also quasi so ein bisschen genialisch davor sich hin erfunden haben. Die ersten sozusagen Computer, die längerfristige Aufgaben übernommen haben, sind gebaut worden, um feindliche Funksprüche zu entschlüsseln und um Geschossflugbahnen zu berechnen und dann später, um bestimmte militärische Aufgaben zu übernehmen. Der Joseph Weizenbaum hat in seinem berühmten Buch die Macht der Computer und die Ohnmacht der Vernunft beschrieben, recht umfangreich, wie zum Beispiel während dem Vietnamkrieg Luftaufnahmen, das was heute diese sogenannten Airwärtsflugzeuge machen, ist damals also noch ziemlich ein bisschen zu Fuß gemacht worden. Das heißt, da sind Aufklärungsflugzeuge geflogen, da hat man richtige analoge Fotos gemacht mit hochauflösenden Kameras. Diese Fotos sind in Rechenzentren geflogen worden, davon standen welche in Deutschland. Deswegen hat die RAF irgendwann mal später in Stuttgart eine Ecke von einem Rechenzentrum weggesprengt. Das ist auch noch so ein kleines historisches Schnörkel. Jedenfalls sind diese Fotos eingescannt worden und die kamen dann in einen Computer, die irgendwelche Leute programmiert haben. Jedenfalls fütterte irgendjemand diese Fotos in den Computer rein, drückte auf den Knopf. Und vorne kamen diese Fotos mit so Vierecken versehen wieder raus, sogenannte Killboxes. Und das hieß, diese Fotos gingen dann an die Luftstreitkräfte und innerhalb dieser Killboxes, auf diesen Karten, durften Kampfjägerpiloten auf alles schießen, was sich bewegt. So, jetzt kannst du sagen, wenn da ein Zivilist getötet worden ist, weil irgendein Kampfjägerpilot in so einer Killbox auf irgendetwas geschossen hat, was da unten am Acker rumkrabbelt, wer ist schuld, wer ist verantwortlich? Der, der das Programm geschrieben hat, der, der den Scanner reingeschoben hat, der, der aufs Knöpfchen gedrückt hat, der, der das hinten rausgeholt hat, da merkt man, dass plötzlich Verantwortung diffundiert. Und beim Militär gibt es so einen Begriff, nämlich die Feuerleitung. Also das ist sozusagen diese Kommandokette, die muss möglichst schnell laufen. Das heißt, irgendwo sitzt ein General, der sagt schießen und dann dreht sich einer um und sagt zum Untergeneral schießen und der sagt zum Unter-Untergeneral schießen und es muss so schnell wie möglich draußen an der Front sein und irgendeiner drückt einen Abzug. Und alles, was dazwischen passiert und bremst und stört, ist militärisch unerwünscht. Und ein Faktor, der am meisten bremst und stört, ist Grubel und Moral. Das heißt, dass irgendjemand da sitzt und sich denkt, das sollte ich vielleicht nicht machen. Das ist nicht gut, was der General jetzt von uns will. Und wenn du eine Maschine hast, die sich solche Gedanken gar nicht macht und die sozusagen diese Feuerleitkette konsequent und mit einer maximalen Geschwindigkeit durchführt, dann ist das im militärischen Sinne wünschenswert. Von daher kann man sagen, es ist der Geist des Militärs, es ist im Computer. Wenn du dir Programmiersprachen anschaust, das einzige grammatische Element des Programmiersprachen kennst, ist der Imperativ, die Befehlsform, die kennen nur Befehle, die kennen nichts anderes.
Tuadis, tuadis, tuadis.
Genau, genau, genau. Und von daher, also das ist jetzt alles gar nicht so sehr metaphorisch, das ist schon ziemlich konkret. Und von daher muss man sagen, der Chaos Computer Club und wir damals sind mit dieser Maschine und mit dieser Welt, die sich eröffnet hat, in dem, was dann nach dem Roman, nach diesem Begriff von von Jibs und Cyberspace genannt wurde, was Leute davor so etwas behelfsmäßig als eine neue Welt zwischen den Telefonleitungen, wie auch immer, virtuelle Welt, digitale Welt bezeichnet haben. Diese Welt hatte eigentlich keine Moral. Also die hatte schon eine Tradition, die gab es seit den 40er Jahren sozusagen, haben sich die Grenzen dieser Welt, ist dieser achte Kontinent sozusagen aufgestiegen aus den Fluten und dann war das da und da war keine Moral und da sind wir rein mit dem, was wir sozusagen aus der analogen Welt mitgebracht haben. Du sollst keinen Kaugummi klauen. Und es gab aber in der analogen Welt keine Regeln dafür, was du jetzt mit einer Liste mit Namen machen sollst oder was du mit einer Liste mit Kontakt, also nicht Telefonnummern, sondern so Network-User-Addresses und so weiter, was man da irgendwie vorfinden konnte. Und vor allem war das so, was wir damals schon geahnt haben und so nach und nach auch konkretisieren konnten, dass es Computernetze gab, dass es sehr große Computernetze gab, dass der ganze Planet schon von so einem Gespinst, also von etwas, das noch eine ganz andere Qualität als das Telefonnetz hatte, umsponnen war, das zu einem großen Teil aus Steuermitteln aus öffentlichen Geldern finanziert war und dass der Öffentlichkeit nicht bekannt war und wozu die Öffentlichkeit keinen Zugang hatte, dass die Öffentlichkeit nicht nutzen konnte. Es gab einen eingeschränkten Bereich der Öffentlichkeit, nämlich die Akademik Community, die Wissenschaftler, die diese Netze sehr umfangreich nutzten und, das muss man natürlich schon auch sagen, die diese Netze zum Teil aufgebaut haben und erfunden haben und sich ausgedacht haben im Auftrage von Behörden wiederum. Letzten Endes sind da aber öffentliche Gelder geflossen und es war so, dass, ohne dass das sozusagen damals schon eine konkrete Forderung des Chaos Computer Clubs gewesen wäre, es war so, dass wir einfach da mitmachen wollten. Wir wollten da auch rein. Wir wollten weder irgendwas klauen noch irgendwas kaputt machen, sondern wir wollten mitspielen. Wir wollten da auch rein. Wir wollten dieses Spielzeug, wir wollten diese Wege auch gehen. Wir wollten diese Welt auch erkunden. Und es war jetzt damals so, dass es für ein privates Individuum nicht möglich war. Es gab so etwas wie Internet-Provider, heute gab es nicht. Die einzige Möglichkeit war, auf manchen Universitäten musste man ganz spezielle Fächer. Meistens war das natürlich Informatik und es erreichte oft nicht. Ich kannte eine Studentin aus Stuttgart, die hat extra einen Kurs in der Programmiersprache Pascal belegt und zwar nur deswegen, nicht weil sie Pascal lernen wollte, sondern weil sie wusste, dass sie einen Account im Rechenzentrum kriegt und dass sie dann, und zwar hat sie mir erzählt, sie ist irgendwann mal ins Rechenzentrum und da saßen drei Jungs vor einem Terminal und lachten und das war für sie völlig unfassbar, dass man vor einem Computer sitzen kann und lachen und es war so, dass die das gemacht haben, was wir heute Chatten nennen, das war damals noch in etwas steinzeitlicheren Formen, war aber schon möglich, also Kommunikation war immer das, was sofort geknallt hat am Computer, E-Mail, das war sozusagen so exedentially irrtümlich als ein kleines Feature gedacht und deswegen übrigens dieses BTX-System der Deutschen Bundespost, da wäre sozusagen dieses elektronische Postverschicken so umständlich und so teuer gewesen wie Postkarten, also man hätte für jede elektronische Nachricht Ja, das ist eine ganz tolle Nachricht. Postkartenporto, also was weiß ich, 30 Pfennig oder so bezahlen müssen. Das heißt, die hätten diese, die haben also sozusagen das war in der Visionskraft von Oberpostdirektoren irgendwie nicht drin, dass die Menschen miteinander kommunizieren wollen. Und zwar auch über Dinge, die Oberpostdirektoren irgendwie für unvorstellbar halten. Ich kann mich erinnern, es gab damals ein etwas fortschrittlicheres System in Frankreich, nämlich Minitel.
Was aber technisch im Prinzip genau dasselbe war.
Technisch im Prinzip dasselbe. Die Grundidee von Minitel war, dass die das Telefonbuch, das gedruckte Telefonbuch obsolet machen wollten und diese Terminals an die Leute verschenkt haben, diese kleinen Geräte. Was auch anders war, ist das, was hier in Deutschland passierte, da musste man sich einen BTX-tauglichen Fernseher um 2000 Mark kaufen, was absurd war, was keiner gemacht hat. Und diese Minitel-Dinger, ich kann mich noch erinnern, da gab es dann natürlich innerhalb kürzester Zeit, als die Leute draufgekommen sind, dass man da irgendwie so Kurznachrichten hinterlegen kann und sich irgendwie austauschen kann, so Kleine anzeigen und so, da gab es natürlich gleich wieder Schweinereien, irgendwelche Sex-Chats und so weiter und so fort, so genannte rosa-rote Kanäle, und da kriegten hier die deutschen Postdirektoren rote Ohren. Also das war, da wollten die gar nicht drüber sprechen, das war irgendwie ganz sonderbar und merkwürdig und da fing es aber in Frankreich schon richtig zu kommunizieren und zu menscheln an und da merkte man dann auch, dass das weit über irgendwelche, also dass das sozusagen in intime Bereiche hineingeht, dass Computer in Berührung kommen mit Bereichen des menschlichen Lebens, die man sich jetzt so, wenn man also klassisch technokratisch denkt, sozusagen gar nicht vorstellen kann oder mag. Wie auch immer, ne?
Ich würde jetzt nochmal den Bogen wieder zurückschlagen auf den Club im Besonderen. Ich meine, du bist ja jetzt so ein bisschen vom, ja, diesem Kultur-Pessimismus, der Technik-Kritik und im Prinzip auch so dem Club als Antithese in diesem kritischen Mainstream, insbesondere in der linken Szene, der gesagt hat, okay, das kann zwar so sein und wir sehen auch sehr viele Punkte, wo man noch sehr viel mehr darüber nachdenken muss, als das bisher getan wird. Also viele Gefahren wurden ja zum Beispiel auch von dieser linken Szene, die den Computer so kritisiert hat, gar nicht gesehen, weil sie sich überhaupt nicht damit auseinandergesetzt haben.
Genau.
Was natürlich auch ein Grundansatz des CCCs war. Erst verstehen und dann darüber reden und nicht einfach veranstalten.
Und dann schon kritisieren, ne?
Dann aber auch richtig.
Und dann verstehst du aber, wovon du redest.
Genau. Und trotzdem gibt es natürlich auch dieses Paranoia-Phenomen. Und man merkt das ja schon, diese Affinität zu 23 Verschwörungstheorien und dem ganzen Doppelsystem. Man nimmt dann schnell für sich in Anspruch, dass man die Welt sehr viel besser versteht, als es jetzt der gemeine, nicht computerliterate Mensch tut.
Das ist schon auch ein bisschen eine linke Tradition, wenn ich das so sagen darf. Ich erinnere mich an die 70er-Jahre, als ich irgendwie noch in Graz war und in WGs immer rumgelaufen bin. Damals hat man sein Selbstgefühl erhöht, indem man gesagt hat, in meiner Telefonleitung knackt, ich wäre abgehört. Und damit war klar, du bist wichtig, weil du abgehört wirst. Also sie müssen zumindest vermuten, dass du irgendwelche Informationen hast. Das ist so eine Art von Esoterik. Also es gab immer so die Esoterik-Leute, die dann sozusagen sich ihre Geheimnisse selber erfunden haben und sagten, ich kenne das Geheimnis des Toho Wabohu und folge mir. Oder ich bin in Indien gewesen und bin da irgendwie einem Mann begegnet, der immer einen Meter über der Erde geschwebt ist und du glaubst es nicht. Und er kann Steine mit Antischwerkraft bewegen und so weiter. Und dann saßen da immer so Leute, Wahnsinn, unglaublich. So fass es nicht. Und dann gab es natürlich, also es gibt so diese Art von Esoterik für jedermann, so für alle Konfektionen. Und ein bisschen, es gibt so eine Tradition, diese Form der Erhöhung des Selbstgefühls. Es gibt, das muss man der Gerechtigkeit halber schon sagen, auch Leute, die tatsächlich Grund zu der Annahme gehabt haben. Das heißt, wo aus diesem Spiel und Spaß oder aus so einer kleinen Eitelkeit auch schon mal eine große Tragödie geworden ist. Weil wir gerade vorhin über Haka-Ethik gesprochen haben, es gab ja im Chaos Computer Club eine Geschichte, die dem BTX-Hack dann ein paar Jahre später gefolgt ist, wo man gesehen hat, dass sich die Haka-Ethik, also sozusagen, dass die Haka-Ethik auf der einen Seite funktioniert hat, auf der anderen Seite, dass der Chaos Computer Club doch aus einer Reihe von extrem voneinander unterschiedlichen Individuen bestand. Es war eine Geschichte, in der also sozusagen hell und dunkel gleichzeitig vorkam, so die Vertreibung aus dem Haka-Paradies. Eine Geschichte, die begonnen hat als NASA-Hack und nicht geendet, aber eine tragische Fortführung gefunden hat als KGB-Hack. Zwei Seiten mehr oder weniger, also vom vom Technischen her derselben Medaille. Der sogenannte NASA-Hack, der 1987 im September auch veröffentlicht worden ist in der Fernsehsendung Panorama damals. Das war wiederum was, wir haben vorhin schon drüber gesprochen, wo der Chaos Computer Club, die Leute im Club zu dem Schluss gekommen sind, das was diesen NASA-Hack ausgemacht hat, ist in den Monaten vor der Veröffentlichung passiert. Da ist in den Monaten davor eine Menge passiert und das, was da passiert ist, hat eine Dimension angenommen, die uns im Club zu dem Schluss gebracht hat, es ist jetzt nicht mehr zu umgehen, an die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen. Also man muss wieder den Schutz der Öffentlichkeit suchen sozusagen und das war in dem Fall wirklich notwendig, weil da mehrere europäische und auch der amerikanische Geheimdienst, Polizei, das Bundeskriminalamt, das FBI und also nehme ich, man hatte immer das Gefühl, jetzt läuft gleich ein Flugzeugträger in meinem Waschbecken ein, involviert waren und es war damals, muss man als historischen Hintergrund dazu erzählen, noch kalter Krieg, da also eine Vorhangstand, es gab drei Blöcke, die sich in der Technologieentwicklung gegenüber standen, nämlich die Amerikaner, die so zum führend waren, die Europäer, die damals gerade eine gemeinsame Initiative ins Leben gerufen hatten, die hieß Yesi, das heißt die Europäer wollten einen eigenen Mikrochip entwerfen und bauen und die Japaner, das waren die Dritten, Das heißt, da gab es eine immense Sorge und Angst. Leute könnten Industrie-Spionage machen und so zu Schlüsseltechnologien entweder untereinander verraten und verkaufen oder an den Osten und so weiter und so fort. Das war der historische Hintergrund. Und was passiert ist, war das, was ich vorher erzählt hab. Das heißt, die Leute im Chaos Computer Club und seinem Umfeld haben die großen Computernetze entdeckt und sich durch die Computernetze bewegt. Und das war eine relativ abstrakte Angelegenheit, muss man auch dazu sagen. Das heißt, man hatte am Bildschirm immer wieder irgendwelche Textzeilen mit ziemlich knazigen Statusmeldungen oder irgendwelchen Äußerungen von irgendeinem verhältnismäßig exotischen Betriebssystem oder Großrechnerbetriebssystem und so weiter. Das heißt, man musste schon eine ziemliche Portion Fantasie mitbringen, um sich vorzustellen, dass da jetzt gerade eine Bewegung von über Kontinente und so weiter stattfindet. Das gab es aber schon bei einigen Leuten. Also ich habe selber diese euphorischen Momente auch miterlebt, wo man also sozusagen verspürt hat, dass man jetzt irgendwie in einem Augenblick einen großen Verbindungsschritt gemacht hat und es gab, wie soll ich sagen, keine Hausnummern und Adressen, sondern es gab lange Listen mit sogenannten Network User Addresses, die mehr oder weniger, ich glaube in der Datenschau, da haben wir sowas auch öfter veröffentlicht. Wenn man auf so einem Datennetz war, wusste, wo man überhaupt mal hingucken kann, also an welchen Rechnern man sozusagen anklopfen kann. Die Rechenzentren und die Großrechner damals waren verhältnismäßig gastfreundlich. Es gab immer einen Befehl, der hieß, Gäste, Visitor, Besucher, der einen sozusagen mal ins Vorzimmerchen reingucken ließ. Man stand da nicht einfach nur so vor verschlossenen Toren. Die meisten von diesen Listen waren voll mit abstrakten Zifferngruppen, die Bezeichnungen für irgendwelche Rechner. Und da gab es eben irgendwie ganz selten Rechner, die einen richtigen Namen hatten. Und es gab Leute im Chaos Computer Club, die irgendwann mal im Netz so eine Liste gefunden haben. Und in einer langen Reihe von irgendwelchen abstrakten Bezeichnungen standen zwei Namen, nämlich Kastor und Pollux, diese beiden Zwillinge aus der griechischen Sage. Und es war so attraktiv, dass sie die beiden mal angewählt haben. Und dann stand am Bildschirm Welcome to the NASA Headquarters. Das war schon ein Hammer. Und das reichte aber noch nicht. Es war so, dass das NASA Headquarters Computer verwendete, der Firma Digital Equipment, die sogenannten Minicomputer, die waren nicht klein, sondern die sind in den 60er Jahren, in der Zeit, in der die Miniröcke auch erfunden worden sind, gebaut worden. Und damals hat man das für einen guten Verkaufstrick gehalten, diese Computer auch Minicomputer zu nennen, also sozusagen denen so ein bisschen Sexabild zu verleihen. Jedenfalls waren diese Minicomputer, die in Wirklichkeit Waschmaschinengrosse, einigermaßen Großrechner waren, die hatten ein Betriebssystem, das hieß VMS, und von diesem Betriebssystem war gerade eine relativ neue Version rausgekommen, in der ein kleiner Fehler drin war. Und dieser kleine Fehler, den konnte man ausnutzen, und es gab Leute im Chaos Computer Club, die kannten diesen Fehler, und die haben diesen Fehler ausgenutzt, der es einem ermöglichte, ohne dass man sozusagen eine Zutrittsgenehmigung hatte, bis tief in diese Maschine hineinzugehen und mit sogenannten Privilegien so zu arbeiten, dass man praktisch mehr oder weniger die Kontrolle über so eine Maschine übernehmen konnte, oder Dinge tun konnte und seine eigenen Spuren verbergen konnte. Diese Idee, diese Möglichkeit haben diese Leute im Club untersucht und haben das ausprobiert und haben zum einen herausgefunden, dass die NASA ein Netz betreibt, das SPAN-Netz heißt, eines der vielen weltweiten Computernetze. SPAN heißt Space Area Network. Da waren die Rechenzentren von sogenannten, also nicht nur von NASA-Zweigstellen, Forschungsstellen, so das NASA Ames Forschungszentrum und so weiter, dabei, sondern sogenannte Contractors, das heißt, Unternehmen, die für die NASA irgendwas machen, Luftfahrtunternehmen, Rüstungsunternehmen. Man war ziemlich schnell im sogenannten militärisch-industriellen Komplex. Da waren Firmen in Europa auch mit beteiligt. Interessanterweise, da hat sich damals eigentlich noch gar niemand so richtig Gedanken gemacht, auch ein Zementwerk in Frankreich. Niemanden wollte hören, warum so ein Zementwerk irgendwie in so einem Netz ist. Das ist dann erst später rausgekommen, weil das ein spezielles Zementwerk war. Nämlich, die haben so Containments für Atomkraftwerke gemacht und mussten immer sehr aufwendige statische Berechnungen machen. Dazu braucht man relativ große Computer und das wusste damals keiner von uns. Und unter Ausnutzung dieses Software-Fehlers haben einige Leute ungefähr 130 Rechenzentren in diesem Netzwerk nach und nach besucht und sich da so einen kleinen privaten Zugang verschafft. Das heißt, die hatten sich dann auf der Basis von diesem Software-Fehler sozusagen so eine kleine virtuelle Klotür oder so ein Klofenster irgendwie eingebaut. Die konnten da ein- und ausgehen und die konnten sich in diesen Maschinen bewegen, ohne dass sie von den Administratoren, von den Systembetreibern entdeckt worden sind, weil sie sozusagen ihre Spuren im Zurückgehen immer auch schon ausgelöscht haben. Das heißt, das Ganze war beginnend von der Idee, dass dieser Fehler da ist, bis hin zu dieser Entfaltung so ein sehr groß angelegtes Experiment, das sich irgendwann mal selbstständig gemacht hat, als langsam klar geworden ist, was da alles mit dranhängt an diesem Ding und was für Leute man damit in Unruhe versetzt, nämlich Sicherheitsbehörden und so weiter. Also um es kurz zu machen, für uns war das Teil dieser verhältnismäßig unschuldigen Absicht, wir wollen am Netz teilnehmen. Für uns war das einfach das Netz, das ist sicher ein bisschen Naivität, aber es ist halt so, dass man, wenn man sich durch diese abstrakten Formen, in denen diese Computernetze damals bestanden haben, bewegt hat, da stand kein Schild, da stand kein Zaun mit Stackeldraht, auf dem drauf stand Restricted Area, zwei Schritte weiter und es wird geschossen, sondern das war ein Rechenzentrum und das war halt die NASA und das war die Boeing und das war irgendeine Firma, die viele große Firmen machen, auch Rüstungsaufträge, so wie z.B. Philips in Frankreich, die Teile dieses Unternehmens machen Militär und Rüstungstechnik.
Die sind ja auch damals überhaupt nicht auf die Idee gekommen, dass da irgendjemand diese Systeme von außen betreten könnte, der da nicht sowieso dazu gehört, weil sie sich das auch alles überhaupt gar nicht vorstellen konnten, dass Leute überhaupt diese Tür finden.
Genau, dass da irgendjemand reinwählt und so.
Und was man vielleicht auch noch mal sagen soll, du hast vorhin schon mal so angedeutet, als du beschrieben hast, wie es so ging, wenn ich den Zustand des Internets heute vergleiche, mit damals, so auch wie das so sozial abgegangen ist. Aber damals war das so ein bisschen so ein Weg über die Dörfer. So man zog so durch die Felder und dann hat man sich mal durch ein kleines Waldstück durchgeschlagen, dann kam man wieder in so ein Dorf und da waren die Leute dann sehr überrascht, dass man vorbeikam, aber wurde dann sozusagen auch offen miteinander umgegangen. Gibt es auch diesen schönen Begriff der Hacker-Fahrschule in diesen akademischen Zentren, wo die ja auch quasi geduldet wurden, wo man wusste, dass man Hacker im System hat, aber das geschätzt wurde.
Diese Flöhe haben sie nicht mehr aus dem Pelz gekriegt.
Ja, aber es war ja auch immer ein Fluss neuer Informationen und neuer Leute.
Wir haben auch immer geredet mit den Leuten. Also ich kann mich erinnern, wir haben uns mal nachts mit, das war besonders beliebt, weil etwa dieses Kernforschungszentrum Zern in Genf, das ist die größte Maschine der Welt, das ist tatsächlich, also auch physikalisch, das sind Kavernen, gigantische Hallen mit Apparaturen, also sozusagen die Menschheit hat keine größere Maschine gebaut als dieses sonderbare Gerät, diesen Beschleuniger und an diesem Beschleuniger hängen ungeheure Mengen an Computern dran und das hat natürlich auch immer eine große Attraktion auf uns ausgeübt und ich weiß, dass wir zum Beispiel mit irgendwelchen wissenschaftlichen Assistentinnen, die sich nachts auf irgendeinem Routine-Job gelangweilt haben, dort an diesem Teilchen Beschleuniger rumgeshäkert haben, also mal so ein halbes Stündchen geplaudert haben, Ich glaube, die wussten zum Teil, dass wir da sind. Oder das ist verhältnismäßig offen vonstattengegangen oder in Form von so einem etwas neckischen Spielchen. Oder von so ein bisschen, das hatte teilweise den Charakter von so Lausbubengeschichten, teilweise war das etwas, also sagen wir ein bisschen forcierter. Es ist nie irgendein Experiment gestört worden, es ist nie irgendwas kaputt gemacht worden. Und man muss jetzt mal, wenn man sich das historisch betrachtet, sagen, der Naserhack war 1987. Und das Internet ist in die Öffentlichkeit explodiert Ende 93. Das waren sechs Jahre dazwischen ungefähr. Und in diesen sechs Jahren hat sich die Welt auf den Kopf gestellt. Da gab es eine, wie Nietzsche sagen würde, eine Umwertung aller Werte. Das heißt, das, was 1987 dazu geführt hat, dass beim Chaos Computer Club das PK Interpol, die französische Finanzpolizei, überhaupt alle irgendwie Hausdurchsuchungen gemacht haben, dass Leute verhaftet worden sind, dass damals erstmals, es gab dann noch einen zweiten Teil, der wesentlich einen dunklen und traurigen Aspekt hat, aber damals, also diese NASA-Geschichte, so wie sie begonnen hat, war unser Versuch, am Netz teilzunehmen und diese Teilnahme zu erzwingen, weil es keinen legalen Weg gab. Das heißt, es gab für ein Individuum, das nicht Student war, nicht Akademiker, nicht in irgendeinem Forschungszentrum gearbeitet hat und nicht bei speziellen Behörden oder großen Firmen war, die eben irgendwo einen Zugang übers Rechenzentrum in die Netze hatten, keine Möglichkeit ins Netz zu gehen. Also mussten wir irgendwie eine andere Möglichkeit finden, die aber auch nicht illegal war, weil es gab nichts, was erlaubt und verboten war. Das ist sozusagen diese Möglichkeit, wie du vorhin richtig gesagt hast, ist überhaupt nicht beschrieben, die war gar nicht gedacht. Und das heißt, das, was eine Polizeiaktion 1987 ausgelöst hat, nämlich dass ein paar junge Leute versucht haben, am Netz teilzunehmen, war sechs Jahre später erste Bürgerpflicht. Das heißt, die haben, wie ich vorhin schon sagte, die Blinden, die Tauben und die Lahmen ins Internet getragen, weil alle nur noch mit Dollar scheinen in den Augen, nicht alle. Ein kleines Dorf in Frankreich und der Chaos Computer Club nicht. Mit Dollar zeichnen in den Augen, rumsassen und sagten, ein Milliardenmarkt tut sich auf, Cyberspace, alle kriegen den roten Knopf, auf dem drauf steht, kaufen und drücken immer nur auf diesen Knopf und kriegen geliefert und so. Und das funktioniert natürlich nur, wenn alle Leute mitmachen und wenn alle Leute einen Internetanschluss haben, dann kannst du ihnen halt übers Internet irgendwann Müll verkaufen. Oder auch nützliche Dinge wie auch immer, ist ja egal. Jedenfalls ist es schon erstaunlich, wenn man sich sozusagen einfach mal in so einem kurzen Zeitsprung anschaut, wie sich die gesellschaftliche Beurteilung dessen, was sozusagen damals rein als Fakt passiert ist, nämlich dass ein paar Leute versucht haben, am Netz teilzunehmen, wie sich die Beurteilung dessen geändert hat, sozusagen auch juristisch. Und das Schlimme und Tragische, und zwar in jeder Hinsicht, war, dass das, was als Naserhack begonnen hat, dass sozusagen mit diesem Instrumentarium es auch Leute im Umfeld des Chaos Computer Clubs gab, die ihr eigenes Ding damit durchgezogen haben, die also einer Illusion gefolgt sind, die da Ansicht gefolgt sind, dass wenn die Russen genauso viel wissen, wie die Amerikaner, die Welt besser wird. Und die sich gesagt haben, okay, wir versuchen jetzt wirkliche militärische Geheimnisse, irgendwelche relevanten Informationen aus irgendwelchen Rechenzentren, die da ja fraglos mit dranhängen, Firmen und Institutionen, die Sachen, die auch fürs Militär von Bedeutung sind, die damit zu tun hatten. Wir versuchen jetzt, da Informationen zu gewinnen. Und wir fahren nach Ostberlin und übergeben das den Leuten vom KGB. Und dann gibt es so ein Prinzip der kommunizierenden Röhren, so ein Interessenausgleich. Und das hat tatsächlich stattgefunden. Und dann ist eine verhängnisvolle Dynamik losgegangen, in der noch andere Dinge eine Rolle gespielt haben, in der noch Leute, die nichts mit dem Chaos Computer Club zu tun haben, die eher mit Halb- oder Unterwelt zu tun haben, eine Rolle zu spielen begonnen haben. Und in der Drogen eine Rolle gespielt haben. Und in der letzten Endes, diese, man kann jetzt vielleicht sagen, etwas naiven oder unschuldigen Absichten, sich am Ende völlig transformiert haben in einen Alptraum, der dann dazu geführt hat, dass einer der Beteiligten die ganze Situation überhaupt nicht mehr bewältigen konnte und letzten Endes in den Wald gefahren ist, sich mit Benzin übergossen hat und angezündet und ums Leben gekommen ist. Das muss ich dazu sagen, ist sozusagen die offizielle Version des Ereignisses. Es gibt auch im Chaos Computer Club immer noch Leute, die diese Version anzweifeln. Die Argumente sind zwar...
Spach aber nicht zu widerlegen.
Genau. Da könnte man jetzt nochmal anknüpfen und sagen, das ist in der Zwischenzeit... Also es gibt es in Form von Vorwürfen und es gibt es aber auch in Form von, als etwas, das man als ein großes kreatives Potenzial bezeichnen kann. Stichwort Verschwörungstheorien und verschwörungstheoretisches Denken. Also der Mordfall Karl Koch, die Geschichte ist ja auch nicht zuletzt durch eine Verfilmung und mehrere Publikationen prominent geworden und immer wieder in unterschiedlichen Formen in der Öffentlichkeit ausgebreitet worden. Es gab noch eine zweite Geschichte mit Tron, auch jemand aus dem Chaos Computer Club, der ebenfalls, ich sage jetzt mal, ums Leben gekommen ist, auf eine nicht eindeutig oder nicht zweifelsfrei geklärte Art und Weise. Und es gibt immer Betrachtungen, Betrachtungsweisen zu diesen Fällen, aber nicht nur dazu, sondern zu vielen Dingen der Realität, vielen Dingen der Welt, die unter diesem Robrum-Verschwörungstheoretischen Denken funktionieren, das jetzt gar nicht unbedingt obskur versponnen und negativ sein muss, sondern das jetzt für mich wieder so ein typisches Beispiel von dem, was im Chaos Computer Club passiert, nämlich diese Mischung aus Kreativität, leichtem, gepflegtem Wahnsinn und eines fortschrittsorientierten und zwar im individuellen demokratischen Sinne, also der Versuch fortschrittsorientiertes Denken und ein fortschrittsorientiertes Verhalten auszuprobieren. Ich sag's mal ein bisschen weniger abstrakt. Wir leben in einer Informationsgesellschaft, hieß es in den 80er Jahren, Kommunikationsgesellschaft in den 90er Jahren. Wir werden mit Unmengen von Daten, Informationen und Wissen, wie auch immer man das bezeichnet, überschwemmt, überflutet, immer mehr Google, die Wikipedia, bombardiert uns sozusagen mit sämtlichen Epochen, mit allem Wissen, in immer einfacheren Formen des Zugriffs und vor allem die sogenannte Nachrichtenrealität, also das, was unsere Gegenwart sozusagen umhandelt mit Berichten über Weltereignisse, ist seit kurz, das ist sozusagen, man kann fast sagen, seit es das Internet gibt, als ein allgemein verbreites Mitte, Ende der 90er Jahre, als ein wirklich mehr oder weniger allgemein verbreitetes Kommunikations- und Nachrichten-Medium, ist dieses verschwörungstheoretische Denken präsent. Und man muss jetzt nicht das despektierlich behandeln und sagen, ok, das sind diese Spinner, die sagen, da sind gar keine Flugzeuge ins World Trade Center geflogen, sondern was ich viel interessanter finde, ist zu sagen, das sind diese vielen Nachrichten und das sind diese, diese eigentlich verhältnismäßig wenigen Quellen. Da gibt es so ein paar Quellen, die sozusagen alle, all die vielen Nachrichtenverteiler auf der Welt, von denen man den Eindruck hat, dass da so ein Chor von Stimmen ist, Bestücken, das ist irgendwie Reuters, DBA, EP, CNN, das ist eine Handvoll Nachrichten-Quellen, das ist die BBC, das sind sicher Institutionen von hohem politischen Anspruch. Dahinter stehen also sozusagen nochmal Behörden, dahinter stehen politische Interessen, die auch immer an wirtschaftliche Interessen, die sozusagen Nachrichten immer neutral nach links, neutral nach rechts, eine gewisse inhaltliche Qualität geben wollen in ihrem eigenen Interesse. Und dann ist da irgendwie so der kleine Internetnutzer, der mit 100.000 Nachrichten beschüttet wird und jetzt herausfinden soll, was stimmt und was stimmt nicht, was ist tendenziell, welche Information ist irgendwie fake, was könnte sein, was könnte nicht sein, oder ist da vielleicht noch irgendwas, was diese ganzen offiziellen Quellen aus welchen Gründen auch immer nicht melden. Und diesen unbezähmbaren Willen zur Aufklärung in allen verschiedenen Formen, der wird durch dieses sogenannte verschwörungstheoretische Denken einem ständigen Fitnesstraining unterzogen. Ich glaube einfach, dass diese Art zu denken eine ganz wichtige und bedeutende Grundübung in unserer Kommunikationsgesellschaft ist, dass man damit eine gewisse Skepsis-Information, eine gewisse grundlegende Skepsis jeder Information gegenüber üben kann, dass man einen kreativen Umgang mit Informationen üben kann, dass man sozusagen Informationen mit Informationen spielt, dass man Informationen fictionalisiert und sie wieder ins Netz einspielt. Es gibt einfach wirklich gute Fakes, die so, also diese ganze sogenannte Urban Legend-Arie, diese modernen Märchen, der Witz daran besteht ja, dass die sozusagen so überzeugend erfunden sind, dass man irgendwie einen Augenblick lang denkt, Mensch, das könnte aber sein, irgendwie.
Das wäre einem schon fast lieber.
Genau, ich möchte gern, dass es so ist. Und es gibt da ein großes Spektrum an Möglichkeiten, was sein kann und was nicht sein kann. Es ist jetzt so, dass es dann, würde ich mal sagen, sehr vom Individuum, von der Person abhängig ist, welche Tendenz das verschwörungstheoretische Denken jetzt annimmt. Keine Frage, dass es Leute geben kann, die sozusagen Sowiskaraktere gibt, die etwas manisch depressiv sind. Dass es Leute gibt, die dann sozusagen die paranoide Variante bevorzugen. Dass es Leute gibt, die radikale Varianten bevorzugen. Dass es Leute gibt, die quasi pauschal bestimmte ideologische Richtungen bevorzugen, die sagen, also wenn man sich anschaut, es gibt so bestimmte Standards an Verschwörungstheorien. Also immer wenn irgendwie im Nahen Osten irgendwas passiert, wo ans die Israel ist, das ist sozusagen eine arabische, klassische Verschwörungstheorie. Also das verschwörungstheoretische Denken ist natürlich nicht nur eine Sache des Chaos Computer Clubs, sondern das ist ein Ausdruck dieser, ein Ausdruck, dass ich als Individuum immer noch da bin und mein Gehirn angeworfen habe, auch wenn ich jetzt nicht über Korrespondenten in 67 Ländern verfüge, dass ich immer noch versuche, mich dieser verzweifelten Situation zu stellen, in der jeder von uns ist. Nämlich, dass wir an einem beschränkten Ort sind, in unserer kleinen Umgebung. Wenn man jetzt die ganze Technik, die wir besitzen und benutzen wegdenkt, dann haben wir einen Nahbereich, der soweit reicht, wie man meine Stimme hört, soweit wie ich einen Stein schmeißen kann. Und man kann sozusagen auch so das soziale Umfeld versuchen zu quantifizieren. Wenn ich mein Telefonbüchlein durchguck, dann kann ich sagen, wie viele Leute stehen in einem normalen Telefonbuch von Otto Normal, Normal-User irgendwie. Man kann jetzt versuchen zu interpolieren, vielleicht mehr als 50, vielleicht weniger als 1000. Also irgendwo da dazwischen ist so die Blase von Leuten, denen ich in meinem Leben schon einmal die Hand geschüttelt habe, mit denen ich schon mal telefoniert habe, da kann ich sagen, das ist mein soziales Umfeld. Und dann schalte ich die ganzen Maschinen dazu und bin plötzlich jemand, der sozusagen adressiert werden kann von sämtlichen Ereignissen auf der ganzen Welt. Es ist vollkommen klar, dass jeder dadurch komplett überfordert ist, weil ich kann nicht einfach mir immer jeden Tag sofort morgens nach dem Frühstück in der Lagebesprechung eine Meinung machen zu dem, was in Tafur passiert, zu dem, was in Israel passiert, in Palästina passiert und so weiter und so fort. Also es gibt die sogenannte Meinung, die ja immer eher so eine Art von Abwehr wie von lästigen Moskitos ist, also wo man sagt, ja, du kannst mich fragen und ich tue jetzt so, als würde ich irgendwie was wissen, aber geh wieder nach Hause. Ich habe jetzt drei Sätze gesagt. Das ist Meinung, das bedeutet nicht wirklich was. Und das verschwörerungstheoretische Denken ist eher was, was so die Schmerzhaftigkeit dieser, also diese Verzweiflung irgendwie aktiv und ein bisschen kreativ angeht. Also und natürlich auch provokativ. Also das ist natürlich so, dass viele Leute mit den Augen rollen, also du weißt, was ich die Leute beim Spiegel, die dann irgendwie so die klassische journalistische Ochsentour gehen und irgendwie brav recherchieren, die kriegen natürlich irgendwie einen Call, wenn da irgendjemand einfach drei Wochen vor seinem Rechner sitzt und sich sozusagen seine Welt sich zusammen googelt. Aber das geht eben auch. Und diese Weltsichten, die prallen irgendwie aufeinander und müssen sich aneinander irgendwie, da gibt es irgendwie so ein Kräftemessen. Und ich denke mal, dass es einfach irgendwie so ein Training, eine Art Astronautentraining-Center für den Umgang mit diesen Informationsteilchen-Beschleuniger-Internet ist.
Das war jetzt ein umfangreicher, ja schon fast, wo sind wir denn jetzt? Wir sind schon fast in so einer Technik- und gesellschaftsphilosophischen Diskussion angekommen. Aber ich finde auch, das passt ganz gut. Wenn jetzt so die alte Realität des CCCs, so aus den 80er Jahren, wo wir uns ja eigentlich im Wesentlichen bewegt haben, so in die heutige Zeit transformierst, unter den neuen Gegebenheiten, neuen Realitäten der vorhandenen Netze, der vorhandenen Möglichkeit, Computerbildung zu bekommen. Also gerade diese Hacker-Ethik hat ja am Anfang auch noch Forderungen, also einerseits Erkenntnisse angemahnt, so ja Computer kann man oft zu schönen Dingen verwenden. Nein, das ist nicht unbedingt immer eine Bedrohung, das kann es auch sein, aber auch so etwas wie der Zugang zu Computern muss frei sein. Das ist natürlich etwas, was in unseren Industrienationen mittlerweile gegeben ist. Projekte wie dieser 100-Dollar-Computer vom MIT versuchen das jetzt quasi globoal zu machen. Genau, die Flatrate und überhaupt, man schlägt sich jetzt eher darum, einen Internetzugang zu verkaufen, während wir damals halt noch Modems illegal anschließen mussten, weil es schlicht und ergreifend verboten war, physikalisch Zugang zu suchen, also sich da galvanisch zu koppeln. Da heuer ja auch das Datenklo, die Modementwicklung von CCC damals. Aber was würdest du sozusagen jetzt in dieser geänderten Realität der heutigen Zeit, so auch dem Jungzugang in CCC kreisen? Was siehst du sozusagen, was nach wie vor Gültigkeit hat? Und was sich vielleicht auch verändert hat und was den Wert der Gemeinschaft CCC ausmacht, so wie du das miterlebt hast?
Was wirklich erstaunlich ist, ist, dass die Hacker-Subkultur die einzige Subkultur ist. Ich habe einige Subkulturen künstlerisch, musikalisch und so weiter erlebt, die denen ein relativ kurzes Leben, also das war so eine impulsive Phase, so eine Mode oder eine Strömung. Die Aufstieg und Fall, die haben ein paar Jahre lang prosperiert, sind dann wie Meteore verglüht. So wie Prank? Zum Beispiel, ja, sind so zu commercialisiert worden oder haben dann irgendwie so ihren Geist verloren. Sie sind irgendwie ein bisschen ausgelutscht gewesen und dann wieder ausgeklungen und der Hacker-Subkultur ist etwas ganz Merkwürdiges passiert. Nämlich, die ist aus einer Subkultur aufgestiegen zu Mainstream, zur Leitströmung ins 21. Jahrhundert, zur Technologischen. Und ich sage manchmal, aber nur halb mit Ironie, wenn ich mit Leuten aus dem Club zusammen bin, wir haben gewonnen. Weil viele von den Dingen, die für uns vor 20 oder 25 Jahren, als das alles angefangen hat, wirklich reine Utopien waren, sind wesentlich schneller und wesentlich dramatischer und mit wesentlich umfangreicher, nämlich wirklich den ganzen Planeten umfassend, Realität geworden. Also so Sachen wie Flat Rates oder so. Ich habe da in dem Intro, das du gespielt hast, ein Modempfeifen gehört und bin fast wieder sentimental geworden. Es gab damals, ich glaube, das war ein Haze-Modem, es gab damals auch wirklich Leute, die sozusagen das einzelne Gerät am Pfeifen und Röcheln irgendwie erkennen konnten. Und es war damals in den 80er Jahren so, und bis in die 90er Jahre hinein noch, dass man immer WEL-Verbindungen, wie bei einem Telefonangruf, aufgebaut hat. Und dass das Ganze jetzt, es gibt zum Beispiel so eine Entwicklung, das ist eine allgemeine Medienentwicklung, die zur Permanenz führt. Also das gab, als ich klein war im Fernsehen, es gab, liebe Kinder, etwas, das man Sendeschluss nannte. Kids kennen das heute gar nicht mehr. Sowas wie Testbild oder so. Also in den 80er Jahren sind diese sogenannten Nachtlücken geschlossen worden mit irgendwelchen Aquarien und die schönsten Bahnstrecken Deutschlands und so weiter. Und da gab es eine Kreativität in so handlungslosen Filmen. Das war ja auch ein ganz neues kulturelles Genre. davor gab es, als ich klein war, gab es am Nachmittag Flippa oder Fury, dann gab es Sendepause, 2 Stunden, nichts. Und um 18 Uhr begann das Abendprogramm. Und dann ist das Fernsehen langsam permanent geworden. Übrigens das erste permanent Medium war das Radio, das wirklich 24 Stunden um die Uhr gesendet hat. Und im Fernsehen gab es das mit MTV zum ersten Mal. MTV war der erste Sender, der permanent alle 30 Minuten Nachrichten gesendet hat. Also es waren zwar Pop-Nachrichten, dass sich irgendwie der Sänger von Aerosmith jetzt die Zehn Nägelgrün lackiert hat. Aber immerhin, es geht ums Prinzip. Und dann kam CNN und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt in der Zwischenzeit ist es so, dass das Netz permanent wird. Dass wir sozusagen nicht mehr uns einwählen und rauswählen, sondern das ist so. Genau, wie das Radio. Du kannst dir irgendwie deinen Finger feucht machen und in die Luft stecken und sagen, hier ist überall Radio, immer. Und in der Zwischenzeit ist es also zunehmend so, dass du sagen kannst, hier ist überall WLAN. Um nochmal auf deine Frage zurückzukommen, es gibt viele Dinge, die in der Zwischenzeit, die wir erkundet und, also sagen wir so, die ersten zwei Generationen der Leute im Chaos Computer Club. Ich rechne mich selber zur jüngeren Generation. Also Bau war von der Generation her das, was man einen 68er nennt. Es gab dann sozusagen schon zu Gründungszeiten eine, sozusagen eine Streubreite von mindestens drei Generationen im Club. Das war auch immer ganz gut. Und das Schöne am Club und dass man sieht, dass der Chaos Computer Club eine sehr vitale Veranstaltung ist und lebt, ist, dass es immer neue 12- und 13-Jährige gibt, die sozusagen im Club rumhängen und irgendwelche Sachen machen. Und wenn man sich anschaut, was die Kids heute im Club machen, dann sieht man, dass die schon mit einer großen Selbstverständlichkeit auf Sachen aufbauen, die wir eben erst mal so versucht haben, uns zusammen zu reimen und zusammenzusuchen. So Dinge wie HK Ethik oder so, da muss man gar nicht groß darüber debattieren. Das ist mehr oder weniger internalisiert. Bestimmte ideologische Debatten sind automatisiert. Also ob jetzt Microsoft böse ist oder ob Linux gut ist oder sonst irgendwas, das kann man quasi auch schon algorithmisieren, diese ganzen Sachen.
Was nicht immer gut ist, aber...
Also da ist richtig was in Bewegung. Der Geist der alten Amateur-Funker und Radiobastler ist immer noch da. Das heißt, da sind immer noch Leute, die Schrauben basteln und es ist immer noch diese Mischung aus Schrauben und Bastlern, und zwar genialischen, also die kleinen Düsen-Triebs und die Leute, die eher mit dem Kopf rangehen, die sozusagen eher geistig löten und dann da kulturelle oder politische Ideen in das Ganze involvieren. Und es ist nach wie vor diese große Plattform da, auf der das alles kompatibel ist, wie bei Lego. Das ist so ein riesiges System Lego, sozusagen der Chaos Computer Club, wo du aus ganz verschiedenen Bereichen die Dinge kompatibel machen kannst. Kultur passt plötzlich mit Technik zusammen, Ethik passt plötzlich mit Hardware und Software zusammen oder muss sogar sozusagen zusammengestöpselt werden. Und ich glaube, dass sich die Möglichkeiten vervielfacht haben, dass sich die Dinge, mit denen man sich heute beschäftigen kann und mit denen sich die Leute im Club beschäftigen, sehr verbreitert haben. Es gibt natürlich immer wieder aktuelle Anlässe. Gesellt zum Beispiel, ja, letzte Woche ist eine neue Volkszählung angekündigt worden. Da wird sicher irgendwie eine lustige Volkszählungs-Revival-Band geben, die dann gegründet wird, weil die Volkszählung ja auch, wie soll ich sagen, zu den Gründungsurkunden des Chaos Computer Clubs gehört.
Das 23 Jahre nach der letzten.
Siehst du, siehst du, siehst du, das machen die absichtlich. Und die RFID, wenn sowas eingeführt wird, ist völlig klar, dass der Chaos Computer Club da steht und sagt, wat dat? Das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an. Ist dat gut? Was kann man damit machen? Was soll man damit machen? Was soll man damit nicht machen? Was macht Metro damit? Und so weiter und so weiter. Und kleine, nette, pfiffige, ein bisschen provokante Hacks, wie diese Call-Volk-Geschichte, die einfach irgendwie technisch sehr anspruchsvoll und herausfordernd ist und dann gelöst wird und dann publiziert wird, wie immer zum Unvergnügen der Betroffenen. Das ist alles Tradition. Und es ist in der Zwischenzeit so, dass es einerseits, also wir, ich sage jetzt mal wir, weil du eigentlich auch schon dazu gehörst, sind ja schon so eine Art Veteranen. Irgendwann werden sie kommen und so einen Glassturz über uns drüber stellen oder irgendwie so kleine verzinkte Säulen mit so dicken roten Kordeln und so Schilder aufstellen, Althacker, circa 1981. Urgestalten bitte nicht nur rüber. Genau, bitte, bitte füttern. Und für uns ist es natürlich, wie soll ich sagen, also schön zu sehen, dass das Ganze nicht, es gibt ja andere Vereine, wie zum Beispiel die Donaldisten, die sich da irgendwie so im wissenschaftlichen Sinne um die Donald Duck Comics, die Karl Marx gezeichnet hat, kümmern wollten. Und die aber das Gegenteil erreicht haben, nämlich dass die Kids, die das sehen, dass da ein paar verrückte alte Herren zum einen irgendwie ein paar 1000 Euro hinlegen für alte Miggimaushäfte und zum anderen irgendwelche merkwürdigen Debatten führen, die man irgendwie als Zehn- oder Zwölfjähriger überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen kann und die man auch nicht komisch findet als Zwölfjähriger, was dazu führt, dass die Kids nicht mehr Donald Duck kaufen oder lesen, sondern sich Akira und irgendwelche Mangas holen. Das heißt, die Leute erreichen mit dem, was sie eigentlich vorgehabt haben, nämlich sozusagen zur höheren Erde des Donald Duck tätig zu sein, letzten Endes das Gegenteil. Das ist im Chaos Computer Club zum Glück nicht passiert. Das Gegenteil ist der Fall, wenn man sich anschaut, wie viele Leute auf dem Kongress sich um wie viele Themen drängeln, wie viele Themen aus Platzgründen überhaupt nicht abgehandelt und behandelt werden können, wie viele Ideen und Themen auch so im Club und in dem Austausch um den Club herum behandelt werden. Dann muss man sagen, live long and prosper, wie die Trekkies sagen würden.
Du warst ja auch beim ersten Kongress dabei, 1984, nehme ich an.
In Hamburg, in Eidlstädt.
Beim letzten war es ja auch. Gibt es da einen Unterschied?
Würde ich sagen, ja. Also in der Zwischenzeit hat der Chaos Computer Club die Weltherrschaft angetreten. Dieses Gefühl hatte ich spätestens. Ich habe ja die Datenschleider wie gesagt ein paar Jahre redaktionell betreut und wir haben einmal es uns geleistet, ein alter Freund von mir aus Österreich ist Chris Scheuer, ein großartiger Comic-Zeichner und wir konnten den, der hat damals eine Zeit lang in Hamburg gelebt, dazu bringen, dass er für uns ein Plakat gezeichnet hat, das wir dann gedruckt und gefaltet unter Datenschleider beigelegt haben. Es war ganz großartig, beziehungsweise einem Schwesternblatt, das es eine Zeit lang gab, die Labor. Und auf diesem Plakat war das Hauptkurs Weltherrschaftshauptquartier des Chaos Computer Clubs, nämlich ein Hochhaus mit dem CCC-Logo als großes leuchtendes Neon obendrauf. Und dieses Hochhaus, ich müsste dieses Plakaten irgendwann wieder aus meiner Garage kramern. Ich meine, dass das sozusagen eine visionäre Ähnlichkeit mit diesem Hochhaus, auf dem dann das Blinkenlight-Projekt stattgefunden hat. Und als ich dann an dem Ort, an dem der Kongress jetzt hier in Berlin immer stattfindet, am Alexanderplatz, stand an dem Tag, an dem also sozusagen Blinkenlight so in den Testbetrieb ging und wir dann da nachts auf dem öden leeren Alexanderplatz standen mit Handys in der Hand und auf einem Hochhaus Pong spielen konnten, dann wusste ich, also so wie ich vorhin gesagt habe, wir haben gewonnen. Das ist schon ein, kann man nur sagen, Fortschritte, die aufs Erfreulichste zu beobachten und zu verzeichnen sind. Das heißt, dass die Spielfreude immer neue Dimensionen annimmt, ist ungebrochen. Und das ist für mich ein Zeichen, dass der Chaos Computer Club weder pathetisch, noch sektierisch, noch verkrampft ernsthaft, noch wir müssen jetzt erwachsen und professionell werden und jetzt laufen wir alle nur noch im Anzug rum und verkaufen Sicherheitstechnik oder sonst irgendwas, sondern der Chaos Computer Club ist der Chaos Computer Club geworden. Der Chaos Computer Club steht mitten in der Gegenwart und blickt sozusagen der modernen Welt ins Auge. Und die moderne Welt blickt etwas erschrocken dem Chaos Computer Club nach wie vor ins Auge, weil das immer noch irgendwie ein Haufen von Wahnsinnigen ist. Und diese Wahnsinnigen, das ist in der Zwischenzeit nach 25 Jahren eben auch rum. Diese Wahnsinnigen, vor allem zum Beispiel, wie das ein Mitglied des Chaos Computer Clubs gemacht hat, mit Hans Blichs in den Irak als Waffenexperte, in dem Fall als Experte für Computer Forensik, und guckt sich die Festplatten von Saddam Hussein und seinen Jungs an. Und andere Leute aus dem Chaos Computer Club werden gebraucht, wenn im Bundestag Hearings gemacht werden und Experten für bestimmte Bereiche von Informations- und Sicherheitstechnik gebraucht werden, wird der Chaos Computer Club gefragt. Es gibt Journalisten bei allen größeren und namhafteren deutschen Organen, die Adressen aus dem Chaos Computer Club, Telefonnummern von Leuten aus dem Club in ihrem Büchlein haben und wenn irgendwo ein Bit umfällt, im Chaos Computer Club anrufen. Also, es ist in der Zwischenzeit ein integrierter Stück der Gesellschaft geworden und aber trotzdem unangepasst.
Ja, scheinlich das Schlusswort. Ich hoffe, dass es auch weiterhin so bleibt. Es war ein sehr schönes Gespräch. War jetzt auf jeden Fall das längste Chaos Radio Express an der Zeit. Ich habe das Gefühl, wir können jetzt noch stundenlang weiterreden, aber das machen wir dann vielleicht später nochmal in einer Fortsetzung dieser philosophischen Aufarbeitung. Ich hoffe, das war für euch auch aufschlussreich, der Blick so in die 80er und überhaupt die früheren Zeiten. Mir bleibt jetzt hier nur Tschüss zu sagen.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Genau, Peter, vielen Dank und viel Spaß am Gerät.